before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it guys we have started with
memberships for exclusive behind the
scenes content so if you want to see
what we do off camera sign up for our
memberships all super chats will be
going towards a camera for my producer
ish if you want to see what ish looks
like donate a super chat today and we
will be reading all of the super chats
um okay so today i have a lovely panel
why don't we go around everyone say your
name your age where you're from and your
relationship status starting with you
hi my name is alex
uh age 27
where i'm from london nigerian heritage
and
relationship status is single bachelor
so name is jordan i'm 28 i'm born and
bred southeast london and i am in a
relationship of three years
hi my name is jessica i am from southern
california i am 28 years old and my
relationship status is single
okay my name's ini i'm from london i am
married and uh yeah be happy to be on
the show
hi my name is ibrahim i'm 24 years old
relations status is a bit complicated
but from paris
oh petty
paris what does complicated mean let me
end on the no it's like a little bit you
know
it's not there yet but it's there yet
it's there yet but it's not there yet
exactly you know
situation situation
pardon situation [ __ ] exactly different
situation you know okay thanks for
clarifying i just wanna
i just wanted to be in them okay okay so
today um we are talking about row versus
wade so guys if you don't know we are
actually located in the uk so this is
something that is going on in america so
roe versus wade the u.s supreme court
court ends the constitutional right to
an abortion so for those of you that
don't know here the way the u.s works is
um
basically
roe versus wade was a supreme court
decision that
made it so every
state had to offer abortions to some
extent now roe vs wade has been
overturned so each state gets to decide
for themselves if they want to have
abortion be legalized or not so millions
of women in the us will lose the
constitutional right to an abortion
after the supreme court overturned its
50 year-old roe versus wade decision the
judgment paves the way for individual
states to ban the procedure half are
expected to introduce new restrictions
or bans 13 have already passed so-called
trigger laws to automatically outlaw
abortion president joe biden described
it as a tragic error and urged states to
enact laws to allow the procedure
after the supreme court ruling abortion
access is expected to be cut off for
about 36 million women of reproductive
age according to research from planned
parenthood a health care organization
that provides abortions demonstrators
from both sides have gathered outside
the court with police keeping them apart
one anti-abortion activist told bbc that
she was elated as her side cheered the
decision it's just not
it's not enough to make this the law of
the land
to be pro-life is to make abortion
unthinkable she said across the divide
pro-choice supporters decried the
decision as illegitimate and a form of
fascism
the bbc's samantha granville reporting
from an an abortion clinic in little
rock arkansas said that the ruling was
posted doors to the patient areas were
shut and the sound of distant sobbing
could be heard before she was asked to
leave this is one of those states
subject to the trigger
subject to a trigger law the landmark
1973 roe versus wade
case saw the supreme court rule by a
vote of 7 to two that a woman's right to
terminate her pregnancy is protected was
protected by the u.s constitution the
ruling gave american women an absolute
right to an abortion in the first three
months of pregnancy but allowed for
restrictions in the second trimester and
for prohibitions on the third but in the
decades since anti-abortion rulings have
gradually parred back access in more
than a dozen states in its current
session the supreme court has been
considering a case dabs versus jackson
women's health organization that
challenged mississippi's ban on abortion
after 15 weeks by ruling in favor of the
state a conservative majority
court effectively ended the
constitutional right to an abortion
so um why don't we go around i'm just
curious
are you guys pro-life or pro-choice
pro-life
pro-life
i say pro-life
pro choice
the you're the only man standing
you think you think you got it today
[Laughter]
come
he said bring it so i'm curious as
someone that's pro-choice do you think
that individual states should have the
right to decide for themselves if
they're pro-life or pro-choice
um
no
okay so what what makes you what makes
you
be pro-choice
i just think
women should have
the rights over their bodies okay and i
think i think that stats of i think
that's that can be considered a
conservative value isn't it
freedom
civil liberties i think is called
something
that's a conservative value like freedom
like the whole idea of freedom
autonomy etc
so um
when would you say that life begins like
how when are they allowed to get an
abortion up to the day before they're
gonna give birth or like what point
i think
the access to abortion within the first
three months of pregnancy was is fair
i think after that it gets a bit sticky
um but i think because you know the life
starts at conception right so
um
yeah so that's that's that's when life
starts but i think having access to
abortion within the first few months is
is fair after that it's it's it's very
just it's a bit sticky okay so do you
not think it's a human in the first
three months or what what makes you
think because you said it's about a
woman's body right but if it's about a
woman's body then she should have an
abortion up to nine months
yeah but i think
when there's when there's a life
involved after three months that the
person or the embryo is developed to a
certain point
i think it's it's very
i think people are a bit too invested at
that point so
the way i see it is right do you think
it's abortion if you take the morning
after pill
um i don't know enough about the morning
after pill to say one way or the other
the morning after paul works by well
some of them work by making sure that
the egg can't stick to the um
the wall
of the vagina and so the pregnancy can't
kind of move forward in that sense but
the egg has already been fertilized at
that point
um so do you think that's like
killing a life
um the way you've described it yeah
probably
yeah i think i think the idea of when
something is like a sentient life
that has these kind of civil rights is a
bit sticky but
for me the first three months sounds
like a reasonable point um
yeah three months
three months
like that's a long time to
be like oh i have something growing
inside me
and
like we're having too man
like
you would you have three months if you
if you know you don't want a baby
like
take the cautions that you need to know
you don't want yes there's extreme
situations to where that's not uh
that's not an option but three months
that is 90 days you're just chilling
there you're like hmm
i want this baby or not want this baby
and just like i don't but it's that's
such a long time three months yeah not
even that though the whole three months
thing is arbitrary why three months why
not six months yeah why not to nine
months who makes that decision yeah
i think there was science that three
months is a critical point in
development of an embryo or i think
maybe when the brain is like developed
at a certain point or something i will
disagree and i'll tell you why because i
have experience of this unfortunate this
is a personal story
me and my wife had a miscarriage back in
november gratefully above we got
pregnant soon afterwards
we had a scare with our current
pregnancy when she was six weeks but
they could detect a heartbeat at six
weeks does that change your view
they could detect a heartbeat at six
weeks yeah
cricket
doesn't
it doesn't really change my point of
view but it is this is this is a very
sticky situation right because it's a
life
yeah this was six weeks so i think
justifying any sentimental justification
of like you know because it's a life and
there's a heartbeat you know we should
restrict a woman's right to carry it to
term or not
i think you know if you're that that
kind of concern about you know the idea
of us a life has got a heartbeat then
your main focus should be on avoiding
that situation of pregnancy in the first
place yeah but not not taking away
someone's right to choose whether to
take a pregnancy yeah but again this was
the same argument with slavery because
they said that the rights belong to the
owner not to the slaves themselves
what would you say about that because
they could the argument you're using was
the same argument slave masters used
no i don't think it was no they did they
did they said that the slaves were their
property is their right to do what they
wish with their property because they
categorized there differently you've
just done the same thing
firstly
slaves
are factually a human being is actually
not the property of another human being
who determines that
i think that's self-evident right isn't
that i would say uh life conception
self-evident but people are disagreeing
with that some people say that black
people were three-quarters of a human
being i think the supreme court did say
that at some point with black people in
america so are you telling me that there
are
cases where a human being is the
property of another human being yes
there was yes no but that's like do you
believe that's like an objective
universal truth no i believe that human
beings are creating an image of god and
they don't know the properties of anyone
but you're just saying that they're
competitive stop there stop that that's
enough
so so therefore that makes your point
mute because you just said it's good
that the slave master used that argument
but you've also just admitted that the
argument is false because a human being
cannot be the people no i'm just saying
that the difference is it's a category
thing the same argument no it's the same
argument because you're dehumanizing
that um that embryo
and that's what the slave masters did
with black people
very vague argument but
i'll let some of it slide right so this
idea of like at what point is a human
being
right so
again that that gets sticky you could
you could call an an embryo like like
like a you know a few hours old a human
being you call that a person name it if
you want
um i think you have to have brain
development to a certain extent
to be
a person
i think we're making this categories
we've got to be consistent so for
example if we say what defines a human
being is brain activity does that mean
if someone is hasn't got brain function
they're no longer human
this we've got to be consistent with
this argument
but we're making these categories and
brain activity is at five um five or six
weeks yeah okay five or six weeks
and you said abortion up to three months
up to three months yeah
so what point is a human being
personally i think until the baby's been
actually born
that's that's the point or i think
past a certain level maybe six months
when there's a certain level it's it's
like a foreground babe the brain is
fully developed
well you know some babies have survived
at 21 weeks
yeah
so you wouldn't say it's a baby at 21
weeks
no i would say i would say it depends on
if you want to keep it or not
right it depends if you want to keep it
or not no but
i could use that argument when it's out
the womb
when the baby's been born then it's like
all right fine and i think to the point
where the baby's fully developed but
there is a long stage in between that
right where it goes from a fertilized
embryo to a fully developed human being
now we can have a debate as to like at
what point is this legit a person name
it steve
you know we're all waiting for this guy
to come out and at what point is it just
an egg and a sperm cell is it just the
ingredients of life well you know it has
a unique dna sequence from the moment of
conception that's it that's different
from the mom and the dads
so and that and that dna sequence has
things like their personality their eye
color
their skin color
yeah but it's not developed it doesn't
have any hair eye or skin or a brain
wrap right so
i mean there's brain activity at five
six weeks
well maybe it has neurons but i doubt
like fully developed brain activity
what do you what do you mean by fully
developed brain activity things like the
ability to sense feel pain
etc it's like when the lungs have formed
except you know there's all these well
how would you know if it feels pain
well they can they can measure that with
embryos in development and say well that
the baby has enough neurons now well we
know like it feels it has
um i mean it's actually not conclusive
between ob gyn so i've watched a couple
different videos and some argue that
they feel pain quite early because when
you're looking at the procedures like
they wince as if they're in pain yeah
like at like um
yeah yeah so it's not it's not
conclusive
yeah shouldn't it be like for example
let's say you're driving down that dark
alleyway and you think you see a human
being on the road would you not be
cautious and you're not 100 sure but
you're not because okay let me slow down
just in case it is a human being so
right now what we've just said now
you're not 100 sure where life begins so
should we take the safe option and say
that life just because that's conception
because you're saying three weeks then
we've just pearls just said okay brain
activity starts at five weeks i told you
our current pregnancy we detected the
heartbeat at six weeks
you know and if we say three months why
not six months
and if you're saying it has to be
development so what you're saying what
we categorize for what categorizes as a
human being is geography where the baby
is located in the womb without the womb
that's a bit dangerous
i get what you're saying and i guess
it's the point of when when do you
define life but i i personally think
well until the baby's been born
someone's having to carry that baby to
term it's developing in the womb
therefore it should be that person's
choice whether to terminate that
pregnancy or not okay so why isn't it my
choice to terminate the pregnancy a week
before i give birth that's messed up so
that's why i say i agree with after
those three months there being like more
restrictions because obviously it's
becoming closer and closer to lack of
you know a fully formed human baby and
so obviously there's all these
sentimental elements to it
but very early in the pregnancy stage i
would say three three months sounds
reasonable i don't i'm not a biologist i
don't know the specific stages of
development of an embryo but three
months sounds like a reasonable point
where like you know it's not a fully
formed person maybe it has a heart but
that doesn't mean like that's a human
being yet come on
so if the if so from the moment it's
conceived
if the development the moment is
conceived begins do you not consider the
baby to actually be its own independent
life
well it's not independent because it
needs the mother to carry out the term
right right but the fact that it is
developing from that moment the fact
that it is developing in and of itself
into a fully fledged human being yeah do
you not think the fact that there is
enough life in it to actually develop
into a human being
um
that that alone
stands to say that this is its own
individual life form it deserves its own
individual riots
at what point
did anybody decide
and you said it best it's an arbitrary
timeline
who decided at any point that you can
just terminate the pregnancy
where did three months come from why not
six months
i'm pretty sure it's based on some
science no it's not no it's not it's
arbitrary it just tells an arbitrary
number yeah because three months just
sounds uh less compromised between the
pro-life guy people on the abortion guys
let's say three months but like i said
it's a slippery slope because once she
gave them that they want oh we won up to
six months then nine months well that's
what you see is happening cause in the
would you agree that six months is too
much because that's what is legal in the
uk that's horrible yeah yeah because
it's it's crazy because there's been
children that have been born at 21 weeks
but this abortions legal up to 24. yeah
that's horrible
yeah that is really horrible that's far
too long but i still think it's within
the mother's right to choose
wait so so you agree that it should be
because i
i'm just a little confused because you
said you agree with it's within the
mother's right to choose but only up to
three months right i mean technically oh
no at any
time before the child's born and there's
an independent life form outside of the
body okay cut off that's like that's not
like okay so just like kill a baby right
but if it's if it's developing in her
body okay so it's a geography let me so
let me let me just i'm just curious okay
so like let's say you get to make the
laws yeah
you got all the power tomorrow
okay so so can we google for this
response
yeah if you want you can you can google
something yeah that's fine um
so
when
when would you
have the cutoff point be
all right well let me because i thought
it was three months but like when we
keep talking you kind of say things that
sound like you want abortion up to nine
months which i don't i don't think is
what you're saying until you say things
okay firstly i don't wanna no one wants
abortion right as it's an incredibly
good before me
it's a horrible thing i mean there's a
well you would think that 40 of women
wouldn't have had an abortion before and
then get another like 40 of women that
get an abortion have had one or more
abortions before and they don't really
track if the other 60 will get one in
the future so
i mean if it's that horrible you think
they try harder to avoid it
i mean
the point of abortion is right you
you've conceived the child is like
you're pregnant and you don't want the
child yeah lack of accountability it's
like a poor choices and they instead of
i don't know using the million forms of
birth control
available they use an abortion as a
birth control i'm sorry but at the end
of the day that's really what it comes
down to for me is the fact that there's
a lack of responsibility if you are able
to have sex
it was recently said on this podcast
that 100 of all pregnancy cases are the
women's fault and 100 agree at the end
of the day
you as a woman have the absolute power
to know whether a man strapped up
whether his condoms in date whether it's
not
picked out with a little stick
so there's holes in it you can wear a
femidom and at the end of the day you
can just simply not let him inside you
so any
any progression to that point to
actually physically have sex i think
why should you at this point be allowed
to
to just get rid of the baby whenever you
choose at what point who made that the
right thing to do well because it's in
because it's factually in her power
anyway i mean this company is actually
in her power actually because because
this this roe v wade is about people
choosing to restrict abortion rights
right so what what the government is
saying you don't trying to restrict
access to abortion but the fact is that
any woman can still get an abortion
right so you're you're you're
restricting freedom you're not giving
her the option to do that
so technically it's also kind of your
problem right like it's also the man's
problem
i wouldn't say it's restricting
freedom
i just
the way i see it
is i don't think it's restricting
freedom it's just giving each state and
there's laws without the whole united
states say each state has a choice
whether
they view a certain way or another way
to make a law concerning their state is
just giving that option to each state to
say do you want abortion do you not want
abortion
and
now it's like if
your state
does not choose to
have an abortion it's just going to make
it a little bit more difficult for you
to go somewhere to have an abortion and
in my mind if i if i was
in that situation i was like oh well now
this is taken away from me
now i have to go to another state it
would for me
i would think more of like well i don't
want to spend money to get an abortion
money for a flight money for a hotel
that's more money on me when i can just
be
more cognizant of what i'm doing like i
don't want a baby right now what are the
steps that i can do to not have that not
that have that happen and i talked there
was um i did a call in show last night
and i had a woman that called in that
had had two abortions which again i'm
like what you didn't learn with the
first one um but she told me if abortion
wasn't illegal she would have been more
careful
and i've talked to many every girl that
i know that's had an abortion personally
she was just irresponsible and she had
more than one and so it's like
why why can't you just make better
decisions why why do and why do the
taxpayers have to deal with your bad
decisions yeah okay firstly outside of
rape
and a great great so great great great
okay outside of
grape except on the grounds that you was
just lacking accountability what other
reason would there be to get an abortion
no
honestly
exactly that's not what other reasons
even if you factor in the i hate when
pro-abortionists use the um extreme
circumstances like rape or interest
yeah
um
those only account for like one or two
percent yeah i saw that yeah 98 of them
is literally a lack of accountability
and i think another thing that doesn't
get um talked about is i remember
and pearl mentioned this i was speaking
to a work colleague some years back and
this girl had five abortions
and i remember talking to her i just
recently had become a christian so i was
literally on my jesus ring
and um she literally cried she bursted
crying to me saying that i don't know
why i do this she was in a very very
toxic relationship i think a couple of
days later the guy called me and said
why are you talking to my girl about
this but i think that's what doesn't get
mentioned is the effects of it
as well and i think what gets me so
angry is that when you
when did when the democrats or the left
women don't care yeah they don't care
about the effects because they just keep
doing it yeah yeah
and i think deadly i think when it was
marketed it was always what safe legal
and rare so it was more of a case of you
had to do it because it was a last
resort but now you're giving them a name
to taking them out no they wanted to
pass a bill whereby
if any time within the pregnancy and
they say health of the mother so that
could be mental health
we can literally terminate the pregnancy
i'm like
crazy oh so
sorry go ahead so
on the question of if i was to make the
laws
uh it seems like the brain fully fully
kind of almost
speaking to the mic develops to a point
where it splits into three separate
parts six to seven weeks so maybe i'll
start there when it's like a fully
almost fully formed brains okay so it
wouldn't be brain activity it would be
when there's the three separate parts of
the brain i would assume this brain
activity when that's the case but that's
off like
five minutes of research
wait and what week did you say that was
six or seven weeks
okay okay so similar because it says
it's not until the end of week five or
six yeah but i mean i mean
the point is
it sounds like from what you're saying
about women you know take having a lot
of abortions that you have more of a
cultural problem than a problem with
abortions it's the fact that there's so
many people getting knocked up and
putting themselves in this really
unpleasant situation and i think
poor choices with no no accountability
with no accountability yeah i would
agree because abortion's legal
yeah i would agree in that sense i mean
not because it's illegal but because of
the fact that people tend to have more
than one abortion as you said yeah 40
and that it doesn't include who has it
in the future it's just who's had one
before yeah that's kind of stuff one or
more once you open that door it's easy
like the the first step is the hardest
once you open that door to
whatever it is whatever it is in life it
makes it easier and easier now if you do
that first step second step third step
you end up with five or more abortions
and it doesn't matter what
happens to your body it's like oh i just
don't have to worry as a kid i don't
care if it's literally killing me from
the inside out from all the effects of
it it's just like oh now i just don't
have to raise a kid i may die sooner but
i don't have to raise a kid now
i don't know
i yeah though i still think it should be
that person's choice i don't think it's
anyone's place like even even if you say
oh you know you should be responsible
for the pregnancy within you all right i
guess part of that responsibility is
being responsible over whether you have
an abortion or not and if if you do then
that's that's kind of your business yeah
i would say this though i would say this
though i think saying about choice there
should be choice but why should you be
deaf why can't we have um uh adoption
because there's plenty of couples that
will definitely adopt a kid
you know i'm i'm pretty socially
conservative in terms of less state you
know infringement in civil rights but
i'll definitely pay more taxes if it
meant we could support um you know moms
who have to give their parents for
adoption if that was the case because i
would choose life over over that i would
literally compromise on that a bigger
social state for that okay go ahead
doesn't sound like conservatives will
like that
you've got compromise you know what's
crazy to support kids
every conservative every person that i
know that's adopted is conservative
oh yeah like i don't actually know
anyone that's liberal that adopted
that's because most of them are pro-life
yeah
okay
so
i don't really understand the narrative
that a lot of liberals
tend to make which is that kid like that
conservatives don't care about the kid
after they're born because
a lot of catholic organizations are
really involved when it comes to
adoption and
um every again every person that i know
that's adopted is conservative well not
just adoption it's about kids in general
right people who are you know children
who are disadvantaged by virtue of being
born to
parents who don't have many resources in
the wrong area etc that's that all
factors into abortion right so if if
you're so pro-life then i guess you'd be
for giving
all those other kids a better
opportunity right and that that would be
fair enough but it seems conservatives
hate the idea of like you know more
state state schooling and not
necessarily not necessarily i think it's
a caricature i think like i said in life
you've got to make compromises you can't
have everything you want okay so any
pro-lifer who's conservative social
conservative wants a lesser state in
their private life will say you know
what
if it means that um more children get
saved and by the way it's most black
kids that get aborted in
most of the demographic than anything
else right you know and that must be an
agenda behind that
they will say you know what for the sake
of life if it means having a bigger
state and pay more taxes i would do it i
don't like it in principle but it's
better than the current situation that
we have
you don't like it in principle
i don't like a bigger state in general
yeah i think i think conservatives just
disagree on what the solution is so like
like for example a lot of conservatives
don't agree with giving money to single
mothers because it's incentivizing
becoming a single mom if you pay someone
to be a single mom more people are going
to do it and so a lot of times liberals
will take that and twist it and say oh
we don't care about single mothers who
don't care about the kids but we just
don't like those incentives
and we just disagree about the solutions
so so what is up an aspect of a solution
you agree on
um a solution would probably being maybe
making it easier for couples to adopt
because there are a lot of couples that
are at least in the u.s at least i don't
exactly know how it works yeah the uk is
difficult but in the us it's very
difficult there's people that are
waiting for years to adopt a kid
but then you know on the other hand of
that you have to make sure that the
people are vetted that are adopting
children because you know you don't want
kids to get abused so it's sort of a
double-edged sword but there has to be a
better way to do it than the way they're
doing it now
absolutely i i still think that you the
problem is more of a cultural problem it
sounds like you guys are conflating a
cultural problem with like um an ethical
problem well the fact the issue is
people are
getting pregnant and can't like are
choosing to to abort it so you really
want to stop it there instead of saying
well if you do this we're going to make
it harder for you to get an abortion
because they will anyway
um so surely the social what what do you
what do you agree on is and it ails the
social the social aspect well but the
thing is like what incentives are there
if people know that if they get pregnant
they can have an abortion more people
are going to do it
and so that that's my issue with like
that's i mean i have a lot of issues
with abortion but it just takes away
accountability from women like if you
you shouldn't be having sex if you can't
afford a kid
you made your bed lie and then accept if
you can't afford a kid no poor people
shouldn't have sex
maybe they they should make sure they
should make more money and then have sex
or use the million forms of
contraception that there are
condoms are free at most planned
parenthoods in the u.s yeah well condoms
condoms break um
but you're looking like this is a lot of
a lot of
see a lot of
women
typically make this argument where they
look for the exception rather than the
rule
and and we we can't argue on the
exception how do you know that's an
exception google
google
condoms and you found that most
most pregnancies aren't because of like
people messing up in like you know the
condom broke or this and that it's
because they're just being careless yeah
absolutely yeah you they're surveyed
because i'm like ignorant on that yes i
would all the people i've known
no one's trying to get a kid over here
so all the people i've known is that you
found them when they got pregnant anyway
or you know no no that happens condoms
break it's a combination of factors you
may not notice if it's old is it is it
like five years old
were they on condoms and birth control
um i didn't ask about the birth control
but i presume she didn't take the birth
control
right right i know one person who took
birth control and still got pregnant
twice she was insanely fat
i think she was just insanely
irresponsible because birth control
works 99 of the time if you take your
pill yeah if you take your pill on time
or get an iud
and so like do i do i believe that she's
the one percent twice come on you can't
believe in all these girls they just say
thanks
unbelievable how much involvement does
the the man have
in the decision-making process as to
whether they get rid of the child or not
none none because it's not your body
but the baby isn't her body the baby's
98 effective sorry okay and there's
millions of forms of contraception
there's really no excuse
do you would you would you not agree
that the baby is not her body it's in
her body
no it is actually biologically connected
to her body like she would die without
it would die without her
her support
so support so i have a question to say
that it's
in her body and it's it's her body so
say
this is going to be a very
extreme question
you're when you have sex with the woman
you're in her body so is your body hers
if you're in her body
you're taking that down already seeing
us seeing us like we're not biologically
connected but no technically you are
connected you make that connection when
you're having sex with a female so is
your body now hers his connection to dna
yep so if she asks you whose body is it
you're gonna be like yours
[Music]
that doesn't quite make sense but
you could even if we're gonna use that
argument you could still if it's about
her body then she can have an abortion
the week before she gives birth that's
the only way you're going to be idol
like your ideology is going to be
consistent yeah and
it is it is consistent to that to that
to that level i'm just saying that would
also be incredibly unpleasant for
everyone involved right so it would
probably be better if people could have
access to that and do that
far before that stage so outside
we're not jumping to the conclusion that
like i like because i believe women
should have you know autonomy over their
bodies that i like abortion and i'm like
yeah just just kill the kids you know it
doesn't matter when a second before it's
born just kill it so if we're gonna use
the argument that it's her body would
you not agree that given the sperm has
come from the man and the man is now
technically inside her that is he should
have involvement in the decision-making
process because he is technically inside
of her he's now technically her body
two people have to commit the act so why
does he not have a decision well when
the kid's born i think he's he obviously
should have a decision but what decision
does he have then when the kid's born
yeah because he's now stuck with 18
years of child support
well you can choose to be a part of the
child's life you can have a say in how
the child is raised et cetera why can't
he have a say before why can't he have a
say before because that's the old
argument because
the child is being incubated or growing
in a woman's body so if it's being
incubated in her body and she gets the
ultimate decision to decide whether to
terminate that pregnancy yeah the
argument's gone around and 100 agree
should that man not have the right to
opt out of 18 years of child support
before the baby comes about i think yeah
i think financial abortion is fair
and how many women would not have an
abortion if that was the case that would
that would solve the problem in a lot of
ways so it's a mentality problem it's a
lack of accountability problem like paul
said yeah i think it's a social problem
as well like from what i'm hearing
you're saying all these women are just
taking a lot of abortions that's nuts i
mean listen this is the uk so we don't
really you know that's mad like people
have one abortion here and they just
like you know they strap up and it's
cool
i'm seeing on twitter people are like
i've had 18 abortions and i want one
more you know that kind of stuff
it sounds like you guys are conflating
like a social issue with like uh oh
should we allow people the freedom to do
you know bodily autonomy what they want
with their body but let's not let's not
like you know trying to oversimplify
each other's thoughts to say oh some
people love killing babies and some
people don't no i just believe you know
some people love being irresponsible and
they continue to do it because there's
nothing that stops them
because why like what's the best what's
the what's the best predictor of future
behavior past behavior
so if a girl's had an abortion why
wouldn't she do it again yep but i think
there are other ways of making people
accountable than restricting their
rights in that in that way
okay
um
the financial abortion is one one aspect
um well they would still get an abortion
then
wouldn't they wouldn't they just get
more because they can't get the check
i think there would be a lot there would
be a lot more careful about whether they
actually end up getting pregnant because
they would know that they're not there's
no financial incentive exactly it's lack
of accountability that's all it comes
down to
don't be extremely careful about that um
i think another way you could stop
society i mean i mean the whole birth
control thing is
maybe better forms of contraception
maybe like just a more societal because
i don't think i don't think all
countries have the same issue with the
number of abortions yeah i think i think
the issue is so why is that then why is
this americans are having hello
abortions
and have the same rights
they have a
good amount too yeah yeah
yeah yeah i think also hold on sorry
no you keep going yeah i think that the
issue is we're more focusing on the
fruit but the root
the root is um i think is it uh andrew
breitbart he was a conservative
commentator i think he passed away some
years ago he said politics is down
stream of culture yeah so i agree with
you that in terms of
if we want to get the politics where
we've got to get the culture right so
there has to be more shame in terms of
you know um
not more shame i don't know
oh yeah let's bring oh i i have strong
feelings let's bring back shane
you should be ashamed i'm sorry you
should be ashamed if you get pregnant
outside of marriage and i'll just
quickly say you should be ashamed
although this is all you're married
before you carry but a lot of people
like uh
red pillow
you know
i agree with a lot of a lot of the
philosophy in that and a lot of people
don't want to get married what's wrong
with okay fine committed relationship or
marriage that's fine too but a
committee's relationship can end at any
time and it can also can
so
what as in like legally
a marriage starting and ending is
different in a legal sense a committed
relationship right you're right let's go
back to marriage never mind just
marriage okay fine
um
i'm just saying like like girls but half
the time they're getting abortions it's
not even from the guy they're with it's
from the guy that won't wife her
you're a side chick
you're a side chick and you trying to
get pregnant so he'll stay
sorry and we incentivize this behavior
either that or they get financial aid at
the end yeah so
they get abortions from the guy that
won't wife them yeah because a lot of
times they do it to get closer to them
and then he's like i don't want anything
to do with
uh yes that's the mentality thing you
gotta fix instead of being that's why
you should bring back shame yeah bring
back shame you should be ashamed and
plus it's incentive as well because what
it will do it will actually um
sort of um
incentivize the man if i want to get the
goal get the girl i've got to bring the
the bacon i've got to have my ducks in
in a row i've gotta have the financial
support before i can say okay now i can
marry this girl and obviously plant my
seed
it would incentivize men to be more more
responsible
because what thing about it what the if
you've been abortion yeah but what the
abortion what the feminists did was
actually incentivize men just to be
continued to be bastards
okay in a sense houses a small
percentage of men one in three men under
30 year-over-year yeah
so
feminism encouraged men to be
responsible against that yeah more
more irresponsible just literally
yeah the woman pressured the woman to a
board yeah it did yeah like you just go
out and do what you want you know like
you know you know what i'm gonna do
whatever one of us should just i mean
you know the red pill stats that 80 100
of women want 20 a man yeah and
and 100 did you say yeah 100 of women
want 20 percent of men so it was 80 of
them i mean that's the stat they use but
if you really ask the woman that 100
percent
the bottom 20 just knows they ain't
gonna get i don't know one woman who
wants a bum yeah no weird no
okay
and and so you're letting a smaller and
smaller percentage of guys sleep with
more girls because again there's no
consequence
and i put it more on the women because
we're the gatekeepers to size yep
exactly
so if you're gonna if you're gonna tell
a guy do you want to get married or
screw a bunch of hoes like what the f
what is this exactly so if pregnancy
takes place the hundred percent of the
illness is on her like yeah just said
she's the gatekeeper if you let a man
inside you you had the option to
make sure you had a condom make sure it
was in date make sure you was
contracepted up make sure you defend it
on yeah and to essentially just say [ __ ]
i'm not gonna have sex send off well
that's the thing like we made our bed
why can't we lie in it we made our bed
you didn't have to have sex yeah but i
think both people make that bed so the
idea that it's it's okay okay 100 the
women's responsibility i think is really
okay i'll give i'll give one percent the
guy one percent the guy because he
here's why okay because it as a girl
this is the option that i have one i can
get on birth control on top of that i
can get an iud on top of that i can
practice abstinence on top of that i can
get pregnant and get an abortion on top
of that i can give that baby up for
adoption on top of that i can use the
plan b pill
i have all six of those forms of
contraception the guy can use a condom
and you know what he can do
what i can do i can steal it and
inseminate myself that happens a lot
yeah
it's a sports person all that happens a
lot i mean why why was the nba telling
them to flush their condoms
you just said that they both make their
bed but they don't because women have
the ability to just abort when they want
but he's if she decides to keep it he is
still stuck with the 18 years of child
support and even if she decides to abort
it he has no choice in the matter he
can't just walk away and say
you're having a child i'm going to walk
away from the 80s of abortion so
technically speaking i get that but you
know as we've said i still i definitely
believe in financial abortion so so if
let's just assume that like
it is fair to say the man should
shouldn't be on the hook for um
for the baby whether when it's had or
not right
so
factoring that in
i think it's the fact is you have to
have a sperm and an egg right so as a
man i know that there's a lot of things
you can do to prevent a pregnancy
um
but i don't know i think it's just
really lacking to say
oh it's not it's not your fault it's 100
the woman's fault because well
technically she has all the power right
she can choose to so you have a problem
with her freedoms so i think as a man i
take accountability in it so the way i
see it is well maybe you should try and
have kids with people who want to have
the kid
um and that's probably on you like both
of you had to have sex and one of you
had to [ __ ] up but i don't know i don't
have a problem with women's freedom i
have a problem with women being
irresponsible
that's that's my issue and having no
consequences
that that's a hundred percent my issue
because i just think in this day and age
take out grape right let's not argue
about grape but like you have no excuse
none
and even if the woman was to miscarriage
which obviously isn't abortion and of
itself
but that is again that's the exception
to the rule nobody plans on abortion
sorry nobody plans a miscarriage it's in
nobody's intent
but you have complete control over an
abortion and and you can see it because
40 of women
already had an abortion
i have a question for the men if a woman
was more vocal about when she's the most
fertile or when she
is in the time where it's like
if you have sex with me right now there
is
a either 50 to 100 chance that i could
have a baby would you have sex with that
woman it really depends how much
it depends on don't know what stage i'm
in like if i'm not ready
[Laughter]
you know like if if you're not ready to
have a kid then i wouldn't then just
strap up why is that so hard yeah yeah
just wait a minute yeah
but like
what is this idea that like mistakes
don't happen often
like condoms is like some full safe
come on man they're not but the man can
still like if she turns around and says
50 to 100 percent chance i'll get
pregnant he can still have sex with you
and have contraception
or ensure that she does why can't she
condoms are 98 effective if they don't
rip
i have i have i i say this from
experience they they rip a lot
i've never had a competition
are you getting the right size are you
buying an audi brand
buying the poundland brand you get
you're getting all sorts of brands
you're getting trojans
have you been looking for a discount
you've been looking for a bargain yeah i
have sex a lot so i was shocked
bargaining
gotta get this bargain
there's a hundred packs yeah
we're getting the flavored kind
the biodegradable i am an expert in
amazon condoms though
amazon condo
hey what do you mean i'm not boots
boots super strong they don't break
boots it's not a brand no the boots you
know like they're store boots
they have good quality
famous brands
better yet why is strawberry
milkshake they're free why does
everybody pay for condoms get the extra
thin ones you know
that's a problem
well some of them are crap i mean
if any condom brand wants to sponsor
this show
[Laughter]
to help these men out yeah help these
guys out
so they don't break both take
accountability and it is both it is yeah
it is it is both like if someone got
pregnant i would feel terrible because i
would be like [ __ ] like you know
you know maybe it was a bit messy when
you took off the rubber or maybe it
ripped and you didn't notice that's
happened before where it's ripped and
you've realized after you're like [ __ ] i
knew that felt too good you know stuff
like that
um
there's so many situations
where you know it happens but i'm
talking from a uk perspective these
americans are going well so i don't know
what's going on there with draken
early fans people
i i would guess it's similar in the uk
i have never encountered i i would it's
very rare that trends in the us don't
happen in the uk
we're more conservative than no we're
not we're coffee
so one statistic that i use that i use
to measure like how
modern a country is is i always look at
the age of first marriage and i've just
noticed that if it's higher like the
country tends to be more liberal and if
it's lower it tends to be more
conservative because like conservatives
get married young but in the us the
average age of first marriage is 27 28
and in the uk it's 31.
yeah
no surprise well it's also a sign of
development right because the more
developed the country is the more
liberal they tend to be yeah
the more downhill they go on
but what's quite strange is right so
i'm looking at the abortion rates per
thousand people it seems the largest the
countries with the most abortions are
like pakistan kenya
less developed countries
and the countries with the least number
of abortions but maximal access like the
swedes switched swiss people in favor of
the pro pro-choice and they have the
least like five per 1000 people so that
seems to me like a cultural problem
right that like clearly people are going
into it with different mindsets so
having access to abortion doesn't mean
you're more likely to have an abortion
but having a really a really flawed
culture and values
is is is the factor
i have russia is number one so you have
uh russia and this one is
as a number one abortions
[Music]
not per thousand women russia's not on
the list i've got yeah i have um russia
vietnam
yeah i don't know i'm looking at the
gooch matcha institute it's kind of jam
oh it's 2017 though
yeah this is
2022. fine
a little late because look
is that trend i mentioned a thing is it
like um
um the lowest abortion rates are mexico
portugal
portuguese have abortion access
pro-choice they may have uh access to it
but it's also like a cultural thing i
know that in
from my knowledge in the um you said
mexico right is one of the lowest ones
yeah that's the lowest yeah
in their culture
it's normal to have a lot of kids and
from my knowledge this is just from my
knowledge it's normal to have a lot of
kids and have them at
not a significant young age but a young
age to where you can build a big family
because uh mexicans from my knowledge i
keep saying for my knowledge because i
don't want to speak out of line but from
what i've seen in california they have
big families and that's something that's
normal
normalized to them
okay i'm going to take a second and read
super chats real quick
okay guys if you want to see what ish
looks like send some money okay man's
always behind the camera we want to get
issue camera and the way it works is
youtube actually pays out by month so um
if we raise enough this month we can get
a camera next month so send super chats
we really appreciate it we wouldn't have
been able to do all the updates in the
studio without you guys so okay he's a
damn good looking man yeah
yeah you would not believe okay so um
christian rennie
pearl everyone is forgetting that a man
can get legacy sperm storage and then
get tied so they don't impregnate all
their partner especially if they don't
ultimately don't want a kid just human
is the state
to be installing personal responsibility
in people's so-called free society
morals aside if something is growing
inside your body why should the state
have any stake in what you do with
what's growing inside you gecko jesus a
fetus has a unique sep separate dna
sequence from its mother is the argument
it's the mother's body saying that if we
cloned both dna samples the outcome
would always look like the mother
higgino morales
um hose mad in the u.s baby pro-choice
these
michael we don't care about the woman's
body we care about the innocent child
that's being killed that's a deflection
the truth to deflect to distract from
the fact that she's killing a baby money
gang crypto shout out to just pearly
things um plus the team and alex show
love via the like button and super chats
yeah guys like the video um i think
there's about a thousand of you in here
last i checked so try to get to at least
500 likes it really helps with the
algorithm
marco beck jordan roughly 121 million
unintended pregnancies occurred each
year between 2015 and 2019 of these
unintended pregnancies 61 ended in
abortion that translates to 20 or 73
million abortions per year just human
what's the responsibility of the state
in determining the destiny of future
citizens banning abortion essentially
says the state has a stake in the
woman's body right doesn't that imply
the woman and child belong to the
government ricardo morales hey pearl do
you have any data on the do
don who levy hypothesis
um probably not because i've never heard
that crime dropping significantly nearly
20 years after abortion became legal due
to unwanted and unloved people not being
born to commit crimes all stare horden
the only thing that justifies abortion
as if the woman's life is at risk
because of the pregnancy the black
intellectual abortion is the number one
reason the black community is still 13
of the country 50 years later mgtow by
logic does the father have a right to
know many abortions
don't are done without telling the man
isn't that fraud to continue to take the
man's money and time
um
okay i think that was hold on
i used the same thumbnail yesterday
yeah okay i think
i think that was it let me refresh it
real quick
um
then
let's go one more
okay um alex baxter 100
aud
okay show me show me that face okay
so um the next thing i was gonna ask
about so
um are you guys aware of who margaret
sanger is yes um no okay do you know
what planned parenthood is oh right yeah
was it i think i know he was okay yeah
so planned parenthood is um the number
one provider of abortions in the u.s
um and
basically margaret singer
um this is a quote from her consequence
of consequences of breeding from stock
lacking human vitality always will give
us social problems and perpetuate
institutions of charity and crime so she
was a eugenicist
and she her whole plan was to limit the
black community by marketing abortions
to them
and the black population would be double
to this day if they did not have
abortions okay and 80 of planned
parenthoods are still to this day in
minority neighborhoods
and on top of that it's still like her
grandson was the head of planned
parenthood in new york
so it's basically the same people
running it
doing what they're intended to do which
is eugenics
does that is that and i know last time
you seemed okay with this last time
why
uh because i'm more focused on the
actual tech and implications not
necessarily like
what what political views the people who
had the tech who created you know who
run the organization have
i think we can we can judge speaking to
the mat we can judge we can judge the uh
the ethics of it from the outcome of the
procedures right instead of like say oh
the person who made it i mean lots of
people with
questionable beliefs created lots of
things right
so yeah to me it doesn't take away from
actually you know the actual problem
which is abortion
and the ethics of you know taking away
rights to that
just you have something to say
it was just laughing in your face i just
to hear that that someone
planned out like this is my plan i'm
gonna sit down i'ma think about it how
can i destroy a community
kill them before they even have the
chance to develop a community that's
something that i'm like yo because
before before i was like choice give the
mom a choice like let her have a choice
and i'm gonna be honest about that i was
like pro-choice then i heard that and
i'm like
why why would i support or
even say like oh i'm for that
if that's something that goes against
what i am my community and
what i was
born into didn't know that someone
deliberately planned out to destroy a
whole community
yeah it's
it's mind-blowing and to hear and to see
people that i know
still support it and i'm like do you
guys know what how this started why she
wanted this like and to hear that they
still support it it's just like
i'm gonna read i'm gonna read something
so according to the department of public
health of every state that reports
abortions by ethnicity black women
disproportionately lead in the numbers
for example in mississippi 79 percent of
abortions are obtained by black women in
washington dc more than 60 percent in
georgia 59.4 percent and alabama 58.4
in state after state similar numbers are
found where black women are aborting at
two three or more times their presence
in the population at every income level
black women have higher abortion rates
than whites or hispanics this study
coincides with the historical
revelations that eugenics dating back to
the mid-1900s
argued that the most effective way they
could can advance their agenda would be
to concentrate population control
facilities within targeted communities
the reality is that black women are
being pushed led from behind into
abortion centers by a caterer of
elitists who agreed with frederick
osborne the leading eugenicist of the
20th century that birth control and
abortion are turning out to be a great
eugenic advance of our time if they had
been
advanced for eugenic reasons it would
have
our word or stopped their acceptance
then and now sanger's organization has
used trusted leaders to convince the
black community that community that the
abortion as a form of birth control is
not only acceptable but also beneficial
to african american culture according to
george grant
author of grand illusions the legacy of
planned parenthood sanger's philosophy
on race known as scientific racism
discriminates against other ethnicities
based on quality of genes in sanger's
eyes
scientific racism in the case of the
black community include skin color grant
exposes singers discriminatory notions
and documents many inflammatory comments
she made during her tenure sanger's
n-word project in
1939 was intended to stop the growth of
the black community abortion is the
leading cause of death for african
americans more than all other causes
combined including aids violent crimes
crimes accidents cancer and heart
disease in 2008 black women had
abortions at 3.4 times higher than white
women in 2008 black women received 30
percent of the abortions even though
african-americans are only 12.6 percent
of the population over their lifetime
black women average 1.6 more pregnancies
than white women but are five times more
likely to have their pregnancy and an
abortion more than
six
i don't know how to read this so 16
million black babies have been have died
by abortion since 1973.
approximately 360 360 000 pre-born black
babies are aborted every year nearly a
thousand per day man they don't like
negroes uh no wow no i think that's a
gross mischaracterization of what's
going on look at the results you want
this results characterization yeah
but boy i mean i think in the size of
him this is
this is a uh a manifestation of what
malcolm x said the media will make your
presses deal press and the oppressors
deal presses
um so what i mean is that the media will
make if you're oppressed it's not it's
not you're not the one being oppressed
you're the one pressing up with people
so
so i'm just curious why
because it's it's
it seems like you guys have mixed up
like a religious fundamentalist point
which is like you know
pro
pro-life
where you you're mixing all these racial
elements that i don't really think
with the n-word project
she had something titled yeah
i i can't like can i say it can i
don't make me do this anyway regardless
singer's n-word project in 1939 was
intended to stop the growth of the black
community right so the whole racial
element she was into eugenics xyz yeah
you know and the idea that this is like
some kind of conspiracy and they're
really targeting black community and
therefore that's that's the reason why
how is it a conspiracy if she wrote it
and she said it herself like she made
the plan how was that
conspiracy the wrong word right but
there was like some
there is like some kind of
wider hidden consciousness pushing for
this to directly affect a specific
community which i don't think is
necessarily the case i think it's more
to do with like
poorer black black
black neighborhoods or black people in
america tending to be poorer and tending
to be the ones most afflicted by the
social on social cultural rot in america
i think those are the two bigger reasons
scientific racism like i'm quoting her
scientific racism
but it's not forced though it's exactly
i feel like they're just not taken yeah
but it's one thing when you're marketing
it to black women and putting and
putting it
right in their communities so
go go go go ahead no no go ahead because
i'm gonna yeah so i get where you're
coming from but it's not being forced
you know i feel like we should take
what's doing well they should take
responsibility for that you know they
made poor decisions you know maybe it
will force or maybe you know like i said
they didn't have the income for it but
again that goes back to accountability
if you know you can't afford it don't go
over it but again i feel like it goes
way back you know it's probably enforced
and i'd like to i'd like to i'd like to
actually i'm correct you single women
who earn 447 000 plus a year abort 32 of
their babies will singer single women
making 11 670 a year or less about 8.6
percent of their babies so it's actually
not the lower income that are doing it
personally i see a lot of
low-income black communities keeping
their babies and having their babies and
they they can't take care of themselves
but they they love their kids they take
care of their kids and i'm like
why are you having a baby and you can't
afford yourself but hey you doing it
you're doing it but there's there's
incentives for that for low income to be
able to take care of babies
and
it's
i
i just
so you know i mean i understand that
personal accountability like i agree
with you on an individual level but you
don't think it's messed up
that
her goal her goal
was to limit the black population
and then she does it and her her
grandson is still doing it
and they're continuing to market it
to minority neighborhoods
well they're marketed to everyone right
but shouldn't they learn from that
though they they
80 of planned parenthoods are in
minority neighborhoods so they're
disproportionately marketing it to
minority neighborhoods
and even it was actually gave me the
chills because i saw them interview like
you saw the video where they're
interviewing um his her grandson on the
street and she's automatically saying oh
this is this is um
this is bad for like minority women and
women of color so they're still doing it
yeah they're still doing it yeah
like like that gave me when you sent
that to me oh my god i got the egg i do
i do agree with you that it needs to be
more of a countability sense
but on the other hand if it's
if it's an access
it's just not it's not
they're not gonna care and like pearl
said is not even the young not the young
but the um the low income is people who
can't afford these bays but they have
access to it so it's like but they
i don't know if this is true but i feel
like if people actually knew
what the agenda was for this they it
wouldn't it wouldn't be a problem but
people don't know but now it's so far so
far gone that they're like oh well it's
here now no more why
why go against this just 62 percent of
planned parenthood surgical abortion
facilities are within walking distance
of relatively high black population 79
of planned par parenthood surgical
abortion facilities are within walking
distance of relatively high black
populations or hispanic and latina yeah
so it's like it's like putting like a
drugstore next to schools yeah like
like literally in california right i
could walk 10 minutes and be at a
planned parenthood and i live in a
predominantly hispanic town yeah and
they had marketing plans to market it to
to minority women and when you market it
in a sense that's like oh it's not that
bad it's not bad at all it's actually
helping you out
people people won't do their research
people won't look into it they'll just
take it for face value and be like oh
okay yeah that's helping me out and
it's
it's such a self-centered way of
thinking like oh me me me me but it's
like
you know that once you have this child
it's not you you you anymore you have to
take care of something yeah but what
about the class element though like is
is it because the assumption is that
it's because they're black and it's
targeted to black people but because
they said it
but maybe
and they actually said we we're
targeting black people in the n-word
project
this is uh this is the quote i was
trying to say from malcolm x this is the
media irresponsible media it will make
the criminal look like he's the victim
and make the victim look like he's the
criminal if you ain't careful the media
will have you hating the people who are
being oppressed and loving the people
who are doing their pressing this is the
sort of propaganda propaganda tactic
that i would call psychological warfare
um i also want to read okay so this is
just a case of an abortion facility um
that
was
so let me just okay on on january 19
2011 black abortionist kermit gosnell
owner and operator of the west
philadelphia medical society abortion
clinic was charged with eight counts of
murder for killing a 41 year old mother
and seven newborn babies unfortunately
unless you lived in philadelphia very
little was heard about these heinous
crimes for more than 30 years kermit
gossel ran a bloody abortion clinic in
black in a black neighborhood where he
made millions of dollars killing black
children gosnell perpetuated the
epidemic epidemic of black on black
crime which is a national problem that
has become increasingly more pronounced
over the years a year ago new jersey
reverend claren childless and i have had
a press conference in philadelphia to
call out the media for the refusal to
cover the trial we then stood shoulder
to shoulder and a coalition organized by
star patrick and cure c-u-r-e to call
immediate attention to the travesty of
child killing in philadelphia last year
i cringed and
gnashed my teeth while sitting in an
almost empty philadelphia courtroom
hearing testimony after testimony of
babies screaming and screeching while
being killed by gosnell and his
employees i heard gruesome testimony by
abortion clinic workers about how
gosnell would deliver fully developed
viable children and then turn them over
to cut their spinal cords gosnell even
joked about that one baby was big enough
to walk to a bus stop he then cut that
little boy's neck and tossed him into a
shoe box it was no big deal to him to
kill these children to slash their necks
as they struggled strained and they
cried it wasn't that grotesque enough he
served off the tiny feet of several
babies and kept them and displayed them
in jars as a sort of souvenir gosnell
stored the bodies of children in milk
jugs and large soft drink containers in
juice bottles 47 babies were found
frozen in the refrigerator they had to
be thought out like tv dinners so the
coroner could determine their first and
last moments of life employee lydia
williams actually played with a baby who
survived a botched abortion for several
minutes she then snipped the child's
neck
sherry west a former employee testified
at gosnell's trial last april stating
that she witnessed a baby screaming
lying on a shelf shelf after having been
delivered during an abortion procedure
at gosnell's abortion clinic clinic in
her testimony she described the baby as
being 18 to 4 24 inches long and one of
the largest babies she had seen
delivered there her words pierced my
heart as i recall how happy i was when
my son lawson was born at 19 inches long
i heard elizabeth hampton's gosnell
sister-in-law who also worked at the
abortion clinic cry on the witness stand
stating many times that she hated the
thought of being jailed after
she was only hired to clean the place i
found it maddening that elizabeth didn't
cry for the babies who were murdered on
a daily basis ads at the house of
horrors she didn't cry for the woman she
held down as they arrived in pain during
an abortion procedure she didn't cry for
the women injured there she only cried
for herself there in the courtroom among
the blood-stand chairs and blood
blood-encrusted procedures was also a
garbage disposal elizabeth hampton
described her job as the cleaning lady
how she would clean out the suction
machine dumping its contents which
included blood and body parts collected
from the suction machine into the sink
obviously she would run the disposal
other workers talked about babies
surviving babies be delivered into
toilets one baby used swimming like
motions before being scooped out and
killed elizabeth hampton's common-law
husband jimmy johnson took the stand he
worked at the clinic as a plumber and a
maintenance man he said that the toilets
got
stomped up on a regular basis he
testified that on several occasions he
had to go outside of the house to clean
the trap which was clogged with baby
arms legs little hands and feet and
other body parts i'm a pretty
thick-skinned tough cookie but the
thought of that shredded flush child was
unbearable i meant
i remember thinking this is america the
beautiful on may 13 2013 kermit gossel
was sentenced to life in prison without
parole convicted of three counts of
first-degree murder for killing newborn
babies in his abortion clinic by cutting
their spinal cords with scissors he is
also charged with involuntary
manslaughter in the 2009
death of
an epi blah blah blah okay every day
children of every race were being sliced
and diced killed in the most grotesque
way imaginable imaginable we must face
the fact that thousands
of children are slaughtered in a
bloodbath at the hands of gosnell like
abortionists every day hundreds and
hundreds of babies are being butchered
every year and by the grace of god we
must not forget what we must
we must not forget we must do all we can
to end the killing and they talk about
in this how abortion clinics just are
not regulated in the u.s and that's how
he was
able to get away with this for 30 plus
years
and now it just regulates it what now
they're regulated no no they're still
not regulated not not well
but i would say this this overturn of
roe versus wade it regulates it a little
bit better by state
you may have those
situations in the states where they do
allow it but i think it regulates it
more to where
like i said earlier if you can't get it
in your state you got to come out of
pocket but now there's companies where
they're like oh it said on a news outlet
that it was netflix and then
some other companies that were like oh
we'll pay for our
employees if they want to go get an
abortion we'll
pay them to go get it and so now it's
just it's just not as accessible i don't
think people understand that they're not
taking they're not taking away your
choice they're just letting you know hey
it's just going to be a little bit more
difficult
so they still have the choice to get the
abortion it may not be in their state it
may be in the next state over well and
the crazy thing there are some states
that are passing laws where if a baby
survives an abortion they don't have to
give it medical attention
they don't have to give it no
no the the governor of virginia was
co-signing that law
so what is that what does that mean that
means they can just let it die if it
survives an abortion yeah
jeez that's horrible yeah horrible man
that makes me so [ __ ] yeah
again the root of the cause is why do
they want to have the abortion why why
are they in a situation why did you get
knocked up
because they're responsible yeah so that
that's that's that's the root of the
problem instead of um the free should we
should we restrict your rights or not to
prevent this but that's not right ugly
but but but they also don't tell women
like i don't think most women understand
what a surgical abortion looks like like
do you have any like they they pull off
the baby's limbs limb by limb they pull
the baby out they crush the head and
suction cup
the baby out and the abortion doctor has
to put together the pieces to make sure
that nothing was left in there and if
you want to take the pill which is but
that it's very similar but they're
starving the child of nutrients yeah
which is why it's so traumatizing and
horrible for most women that do it so i
don't know if it is because they keep
they do it again not only that they
don't see what actually happens i think
i've seen the video what actually
happens in the abortion in an ultrasound
and trust me i think if that was more
in the media literally roll video would
have been cancelled years ago she wanted
to get abortion abolished especially all
severely restricted in this country put
a massive ad campaign or if a woman's
considering it she should see this what
will happen
and what gets i think this makes me cry
when they were doing that procedure like
paul was saying you could see the baby
trying to fight for his life and you see
it you see it it's really like even even
in early term abortions you see the baby
like moving away
from
from the
and it's really it's really like oh my
god it makes me feel so gross even in
that i still think that there will be uh
people who uh possibly could you have a
i think yeah
if
if women knew more about
since it's very self-centered they knew
more about what it does to them because
a lot of women don't want to have
children because of oh i don't want to
have my belly expand back problems gain
weight a lot of women don't want to have
babies because of that if
if it was talked about like hey when you
get an abortion xyz happens to you
i feel like more women would
not have an abortion because of what it
does to them i would disagree i think if
they see it
don't get me wrong you're gonna have a
percentage of women no matter what you
show to them they're gonna get it no
matter what they will boast about it but
i'm talking about the majority the great
majority would have second thoughts
about this if they actually saw like
that vision that me and paul have seen
where the baby is protecting his life
there'll be something there'll be some
motherly ins maternal instinct that
would say this can't be done i mean how
many times do we get outraged when they
say immigrants are coming through the
channel tunnel or the cross channel and
they die on the beach and there's the
national outcry
there you go yeah or the rwanda thing
that happened recently what stopped the
uh refugees going to rwanda but why is
that like a second
course of action why is it like
that the discussion is more around
restricting people's rights than all
these others it's not all right
from our point of view that is a child
so so to us like that is a genocide like
we are watching a genocide and i think
honestly if you've seen videos of the
procedures that they do yeah i think
your mind might change i don't want to
watch videos with someone get an
abortion no i i know but why don't you
because if it's just a procedure and
it's not a child and that's but that's
what i'm saying like like to us that we
care a lot because to us you are killing
a child and can i just point out the
fact that if the baby can be starved of
nutrients which kills the baby doesn't
that indirectly show that the baby isn't
the woman
doesn't that indirectly show the baby
isn't the woman
so your previous argument was that the
woman should have full control because
it's her body and my point was that it's
not
her body is in her body
if the baby can be starved of nutrients
whilst it's developing which kills the
baby as a form of abortion doesn't that
prove that the baby isn't
her body it's an independent life yeah
their argument would be the baby is a
virus it's a parasite not invading her
body but still i'm not agreeing with it
but that's what there are that's not
what the argument would be the argument
would be that well you can you can you
can restrict nutrients from reaching any
cell in your body and that cell will die
you can restrict
to a tumor and that human would die that
doesn't mean like the tumor is
you've said it's a parasite because it's
not a human using the word virus and
parasite is trying to dramatically no
that's what a parasite does biology
that's not that's just basic
biology okay
so earlier earlier you said that since
the baby
the baby is inside the woman and it
needs the mother for nutrients is not
independent what about when it's born it
still needs the mother for nutrients it
still needs to mother the mother to be
raised they can't just be like oh just
sit here on the couch you're you're born
now so you're your own thing like is
that is that not the same thing or is it
different now it's outside the body it's
biologically independent so it's outside
the assist but it's not independent it's
so it's so perfectly
not really it requires the mom's breast
milk
but you can you can give it breast milk
from like what's it well the she would
still
she would still have to do it anyone
could do it
but i'm saying it's still dependent on
the mother it's still dependent on the
female biology whether it's from her
breast or another woman's breast yeah
well a baby is dependent period on
everything around it on every every one
of you biologically we're talking well
biologically it's it's factually a
different entity so
it's its own being now it's like that's
not in anyone's body the baby's there
you're there you could die and the baby
would survive if you died with a baby
inside you then the baby is most likely
going to die as well but there are cases
where babies survive whilst a woman's
dead of course of course but then you'd
have to like cut the woman open but it
shows it proves that the baby is its own
individual question since you said
biology wouldn't you agree that life
starts at conception if 95 of biologists
say that
life starts at conception okay so then
why is it okay to kill a life
well that that point of actually being a
fully formed human being is is not is
debatable wasn't it but i think it's
very black and white the baby's either
an individual um
i'm not going to say person but it's an
individual
entity inside the woman
or it's not it's either a biological
development
outside of her or it's not so once it's
conceived
as it starts to develop it is
essentially its own individual so i
think it's very black and white yeah i
have a question though
let's say there's a pregnant woman and
some
thief um in the event he's trying to um
assault her
kills both the
and as a result of the assault both the
baby and her die
should that person be die but be charged
with double homicide yeah
yep and there's people that have why so
but but but the baby's not being born
yet but i would assume oh that's that's
the life and progress right it's
developing and i would assume and and
the mother
i think you just killed your whole
argument yeah
no no i didn't because i've already said
multiple times that that that from the
point of the point of which you're like
a fully fledged human being is
questionable right you start with an
embryo and then you develop and so what
point do you say that's a that's an
independent human being so she's she's
three months pregnant
but when she's pregnant assuming that
she wants to have the kid then i'll say
yeah well you're going to have a kid so
that's two people so the so the
identity of that embryo is dependent on
the mother's decision
the identity of the embryo so basically
what classifies that embryo as a human
being is really dependent on another
person decision so it's not independent
so it's literally the mother has the
power of god basically to determine the
embryo is either human or just a clump
of cells
because you said that um is this mom's
decision so for example like a mystery
hypothetical scenario is someone oh
there's a woman that's three months
pregnant
she's assaulted
according to
as a result unfortunately both the
fetus and the mum die
should that person be charged with
double homicide or just single homicide
i don't know i would assume double
why what but what stage of development
is that baby axel would you agree that
it should be a double homicide
if the baby is killed as well as the
woman if the baby is two weeks old
it's it's it's not a fully developed
human being so it's a narrow for me then
so
i would consider it a double homicide
because yeah you're killing a life in
progress but at what point of the
development
that's a deeply scientific question i
don't know
what would you consider a fully
developed human being because
technically
i think it's 25 for
women and
i don't know but we don't fully develop
till a certain age so if i'm 15 and say
fully development is 25 for me am i not
considered a fully developed human at 15
since i'm still developing
again that's a very philosophical
question but i would i would say
the later stages of pregnancy where
where the the baby's basically developed
and it's just you know a process of
waiting for it to be born yet that's
when to me that's like
that's like a that's a
that's really horrible
to to abort a life at that kind of stage
um but i have a question for you right
so so if you're in in a clinic and there
is a tray of you know embryos maybe
someone's doing artificial insemination
or something there's a couple trays of
embryo and then there's also three or
four
you know um kids young kids next to you
they'll help the whole place sets on
fire do you save the two or three kids
next to you or do you save the hundreds
are we looking for another exception
are we is that what we're going to do
we're going to do the worst wildest
situation no it's not about i can give
it up
not about exceptions
because based on your concept
is something those hundreds of embryos
are fully fledged lives right so that's
what's important i'll give you an answer
you try and say both why should it be
either or
you try and save both yeah so for
example this is a question that i i get
from the poor abortions i said okay if
the mother's um life is in danger what
do you do
the doctor should try and save both
okay unfortunately in the procedure that
the baby dies so be it but the aim
wasn't to kill the baby the aim was to
save life unfortunately when you do
procedures that's the risk sometimes
you're going yeah it happens yeah that
happens it's a very very extreme case
yeah well so you would you would be in
favor of killing hundreds of unborn
lives or letting them die in favor of
the
he just said he just said he'd say
but you have to pick one
no
why'd you pick one because it cuts to
the cups of the crops of the issue i'm
trying to say of life but so so do you
think those
sisters those babies
those babies
that's different though are the same
have the same weight as those embryos
that cuts to the crux of the issue the
whole point is you try to say well
it may not be feasible to save both but
like i said your aim is to try and save
both
don't dance around the question no it's
not dance around it because it's dancing
around the question is using a point
zero two percent scenario to justify the
full argument it's not about the
practicality okay i'm not saying it's a
real life situation
which is what we're talking about that's
about the theory so you're saying every
embryo is a fully formed life therefore
any stage of abortion is bad that's
killing a a legal human being according
to you guys yeah so is that legal human
being yeah
it's like me saying okay there's a fire
in this building and there's an elderly
woman that can't um walk or there's a
newborn baby who do i save just answer
the question no no no
it's the same scenario it's the same
answer no it's the same i'll take your
answer as they're both the same way no
no no no no
what do you mean no no the the the
answer is
we're actually dancing around the fact
yeah why do you need to actually pick
one yeah i'll try and save both if it
means if in in my attempt to save both
that it's physically impossible
then it's a it's a tragedy
yeah
but i'm trying to um
say i'm trying to say both but if it's a
situation whereby
one survives so be it but my aim right
from the beginning was to say both did
anyone else answer the question but
that's different situations you know you
said they're like what scientific lab or
something like that yeah you know and
then what we're talking about is two
people
you know deciding to do something and i
just started coming up i just don't know
why you're like this is a female
argument
like this is a girl this is what girls
do on my show all the time
let's talk about the point zero zero
zero one percent case that will never
happen
to argue the rule it doesn't it doesn't
it's not a good question it's a bad
faith argument it's a philosophical
question which is the crux of the
arguments at what point is a life fully
fledged life so it's not about the the
idea is reception is relevant it's about
creating an artificial situation or
fictional situation that would have you
directly investigate that premise right
is that embryo really got the same way
as a as a baby outside the room fully
developed i'll i can answer your
question i would say
no the embryo in a
in a tray does not have the same
significance as a
baby because it hasn't been placed
inside
the woman yet because if it stays in
that p if it stays in a petri dish it's
not going to develop the way it needs to
because it's not
inside where it can't where it's
supposed to develop but it's still alive
it's still got it's still in that
potential
so conception to embryo
it's a cell yes it's a cell and
a cell is a life essentially but if you
leave it in that dish it's not going to
develop it's just going to it's going to
stay right there because it's not
properly in the environment that it
needs to be in
so for me i would save the children
because i know that if
i would want to save both because i know
if i get that
thing inside of woman is going to
develop but
if if i'm in a burning building and i
have a chance to save a life that's
already there i'm going to save that
life that's already there and if there's
a possibility to
create that thing again in the dish i'm
going to do that later on but i would
save the ones that are there
so that stage of incubation is is what
what makes it
because it's it's not going to because
there's a key
step that needs to happen to where it
needs to be inside if you like i said if
you leave it in that dish it's not going
to it's not going to
it's not going to probably do what it
needs to do it's just going to stay
there and it's just going to stay in
there we've got to remember as well that
we're talking about burning a burning
building
nobody has a choice
only one person's working there exactly
exactly whereas a woman has a choice
whether to actually end the life of that
developing baby insider or not the
circumstances are so far removed from
each other i just think it's a silly
point to be arguing well it's not it's a
philosophical argument meant to identify
the premises and investigate the
premises you made but i get that maybe
maybe that's going oh you know it's not
there's nothing great the great way to
yeah but it's not meant to be practical
that's philosophy you can't but we live
but we live in a practical world or
practically women can get abortions so
practically men can up that of 18 years
ago support yeah i agree with that yeah
and practically men can kill them um men
and women but we don't do it
you guys aren't against that you're not
pacifist i'm gonna i'm gonna read some
super chats before we get into that
okay guys um as you know we are saving
for a camera for ish if you wanna know
what ish looks good like send a super
chat while you're at it like the video
seriously guys i believe there's a
thousand two hundred of you in here i'm
not sure how many likes we're at but
let's see we're at 515 can we get to six
700 likes help a girl out it really
helps with the algorithm
also sign up for our memberships to see
exclusive behind the scenes content
okay so first super chat house of has
what about cps taking a child away once
born because the mother was doing drugs
smoking and putting it in danger uk cps
argue for the life of the child every
year and take it away from the mother
your argument is faulty bruh that's life
libra
what if she was on her way to the clinic
is it still a double homicide abbey
classic i'll be one classic emotional
individuals always argue with outliers
and exceptions you don't throw a rule
that works for 99 percent of cases just
because one case is a failure john
belcher egg is alive sperm is alive
combining them doesn't make life it just
continues life with a different dna
xernex from rolo brookings institute
women earning 47k have abortions at the
rate of 32 percent um women earning 11k
unless have abortions at the rate of
eight percent abortions are fail-safes
for poor reductive choices reproductive
choices otis wellington the double the
law is double homicide um
china
easy i'm thank you for the super chat
alan maxwell there is a such thing as
evil now it's an atrocity will be more
fully known the moral
depravity of some companies will surface
watch them go broke just human look at
the way the way look at it this way
white hat it's mostly upper-class white
feminists talking about abortion rights
but the clinics are mostly in poor
neighborhoods second the eugenics
movement targeted poor people they hated
the irish too thp
two words tur
tiggy experiment the us has been doing
this to african americans g dash g r um
blar
blareb why do these people want abortion
when the west is literally suffering
from suffering from birth declining
which means the future it will lead to
the whole west if baal john sims bro in
the white hat is talking in circles thp
network pearl literally just read facts
upon facts and the dude in this and
do and this dude has his head buried in
the sand worse than the ladies who won't
accept facts over feeling so digital
sparks the same people who are pro
abortion would lose their minds if a
person decided to abort their pet
puppies or kittens 100 percent
just no one likes abortion
oh my god just human the sad part is the
eugenics angle wasn't even denounced
after world war ii they renamed the
program planned parenthood because of
the optics of the german socialist party
they only stopped for sterilization in
the 70s um
cellul celerial acts showed up late
sorry is there anyone who is religious
and pro-abortion if so how do you deal
with that conflict um and then i think
that was the last one alex paper okay
i'll go ahead and go if there's more
super chess and read them and i'll
say i'm gonna read something but you can
do your comment first okay i was gonna
answer that person's question who was uh
religious and
pro-abortion i um
i used to be pro-choice and
my reasoning behind it was
um
because god gave us the freedom of
choice and um
everyone should have a choice if they
decide to
get in that situation and
get pregnant they should have the choice
to do whatever they want i don't agree
with it but it's their choice but what
changed my
thought was the
was just
what the creator of planned parenthood
and that and just knowing that
we have
a lack of accountability like we've been
saying and it's just like
is not to take away someone's right to
get people to think more like really
think about the situation that you may
be putting yourself into
that's a good answer jeff yeah i think
we all agree on that so um another so
another thing that i've heard um is the
economic impact of abortion so i'm just
gonna read an excerpt from the same
article um if anyone wants to know this
is a
um this is from urban culture black
community news it's a
c-u-e-c-u-r-e document and it goes into
the racist roots of abortion so
it talks about that the economic impact
so very few think about the cost of
abortion other than in the context of
the price to go get one yet the numbers
demonstrate that there is indeed a price
to be paid when the population
equivalent to the 73 largest cities from
new york all the way to the cities down
of chandler arizona have been aborted
movement for a better america has been
sounding the alarm calculating that
abortion drives the greatest health care
and education crisis in history as a
baby boomer nurses and teachers retire
we are facing a looming shortage of 1
million nurses and 2 million teachers we
also face critical shortages in key
professions such as science medicine and
higher education another consequence of
abortion is a disastrous shift in the
supply demand equation that underlies
our economy 55 million abortions
represent a huge loss in consumer demand
if those babies had been born our
fast-paced economy would still be going
strong those we aborted were the future
customers consumers producers parents
and taxpayers we needed to keep our
economy growing the abortion boom is
also behind the crisis in social
security and medicare
in 1940 we had 145 people in the
workforce for every person on social
security
that's why that's when it looked like a
great idea by 1952 the ratio had dropped
to 16 to 1. now it's three to one and
yes less than 20 years it will only be
two to one that's why the government
ponzi scheme will completely the
government ponzi scheme will completely
collapse even before shortages can be
fully realized the immediate impact of
increased sexual activity leading to
abortion can be seen with it when
examining stds in america millions are
affected by the sexually transmitted
illnesses resulting from their own poor
choices and actions in fact according to
the american social health association
more than half of all americans will
contract an std or sti in their lifetime
there are over 65 million americans
living with an std or sti and there are
over 19 and over 19 million new cases
every year only some of which are
curable
curable more than eight billion dollars
is spent each year to diagnose and treat
stds stis and this figure does not even
include the most dangerous hiv and aids
in fact the kaiser family foundation
warns sexually transmitted diseases are
at an epidemic proportions half of the
10 most frequently reported infections
to the centers for disease control and
prevention cdcs are still stds including
the most common chlamydia however the
scope of the epidemic and its impact is
often underestimated by the public and
unacknowledged by many health care
professionals besides the cost to
diagnose and treat these infections
there are other indirect costs that
could be eradicated immediately simply
by curbing sexual activity it is it's
only through sex that these diseases are
contracted abstinence while not curing
the disease would immediately stop the
spread among unwed couples our economies
55 million missing people has certainly
caused a significant decline in the tax
base that will go unanswered as there
are not enough people to support the
economic except
expectations of today's debt latin
america
so um the reason i read this was because
we talked about population control
um
so
someone one of the super chats mentioned
thompson louie have it theory which is
what was the idea that like access to
abortion was linked to
crime rights because when people have
were able to better plan their families
they had less unwanted kids there were
less people who were you know unwanted
and then had all these issues and ended
up going into crime and xyz
um
i mean yeah it's it's an unpleasant
reality
that
there is
there's no positive in abortion right
the fact is that there's that that's a
life that's someone
and you know obviously we differ in this
but i believe someone isn't
has just decided that they want to stop
incubating
and
that has consequences in terms of you
know there's less people and that has
other consequences but i just want to
say also having that kid um i'm forcing
people
to have that kid when you know they for
whatever reason don't want to also has
its issues in terms of crime rates and
um the quality of people that will then
be you know be pushed into society so i
don't think it's as black and white as
you know there should be more kids
but do you do you think that
with this um
overturn of the law that it will
cause the people who can't afford a baby
or can't have a baby to
think more or do you think it'll just be
the same and they'll just find a way to
get it done they will just find a way
i don't think these people will think
more from from what i've heard i've
never been to america i'm not going
anytime soon actually you know what i
went to florida like 15 years ago it was
it was terrible
um it's way too hot over there
and the food sucks but um where i went
um
but
sorry i lost my train of thought yeah
these people i don't think will become
more accountable i think i think it's
such a massive social issue and i know
you know people
good good um i know you guys are big on
the racial aspect but i don't think
there's
that much
racial about it i think it's more of a
class thing i think there's underserved
underprivileged
people who are who are have like from
what i've seen of african-american
culture it is mad like wildstar and
stuff like that these people look like
they've been pushed into ghettos for
like 200 years denied access and a lot
of aspects of their culture there's a
lot of great aspects of african-american
culture jazz and all the amazing things
people did with almost no resources but
there's a lot of negatives
like you know the fact that people are
obviously sleeping around a lot i'm
hearing guys like begging to be able to
sleep with someone without protection
that's the biggest issue and i think
it's in the mind of these people that
needs that needs to be targeted so what
you said about the posters and like
showing people how nasty abortion is and
you know all the raising awareness
around the responsibility of a kid i
think that should be what the
conservatives should have been focusing
on
99 i think that would have a way bigger
impact than just saying hey if you want
to get an abortion we're just going to
make it way harder so i have a question
do you
are you advocating that people in
low-income
communities should abort more
no
okay it just sounded like that's what
you were saying no i'm not saying it's
better for low-income
people to abort by virtue of being no
actually
i think it's better it's
to raise a child you need access to
resources and there's a lot of
responsibility and so
i think we'd all agree if you don't have
a
sizable income or an income that you
think can support a family then i think
it's a better idea it's advisable not to
have one is that is anyone in
disagreement with that yeah don't start
exactly so i guess you can spin it as
i'm saying poor people shouldn't have
families but i'm saying people who are
lacking in the resources to have to
support a healthy family should make the
smart decision should you try and be
more
yeah to try and you know think about it
more and you know maybe delay that until
they do on that um
[Music]
what
what is the
level of
income you need to be able to support a
baby since if you can't support a baby
you'll get government assistance
so like what's the
is it's another greater like what's the
level of income that you need to have to
support a baby that's a great question i
think
at least
at least the salary that's around the
living wage and i would i would say for
for a single mother
that's a very specific question that's
yeah like you get you get so much
assistance that
you really don't need that much money
too
i also have a controversial opinion on
that i actually think based on the
population control thinking i think
there should be
some government interference on managing
people
who have a lot of kids irresponsibly i
think that's it's tough for an advanced
civilization to have people who are
having kids that they may not be able to
take care of that's that's tricky i
think at some point it's like listen if
you if you earn
if you know based on the range of things
like your mental health um your
emotional health your your your income
that you're shown to not be capable of
raising or supporting kids adequately
then there should be some intervention
to make sure that you just stop having
kids then so would you say maybe getting
a breeding license then for people i i
actually agree with something like that
and i think that's where society is
going
absolutely no
okay no no come on
i think in the future i think that's
going to be the case i think raising a
kid is a massive responsibility and i'm
i'm i'm not a fan of the more
traditional mindset of like just raise a
kid see what happens i know someone said
something about having nine kids in
nigeria in our last talk and as a
nigerian i'm like dude there's a hell of
poverty in nigeria it sounds like you're
saying poor people shouldn't reproduce
no they sh they should
but
they need to be more
cautious
the consequences of being poor
because that affects the children and
that and those children affect society
so so i think saying they shouldn't
reproduce is is a bit of a
mischaracterization i'm not saying by
virtue of being poor but you have to
agree that you shouldn't be poor if
you're having kids right well you're
saying it's okay to i think poor people
should be able to have kids if they want
to have kids and they have two parents
in the home and not only that
circumstances can change like if the man
is the breadwinner that was to say that
he can't get a higher paying job that's
fair enough but that that would mean
that they're somewhat capable of
supporting a child that's not
poor to me is different poor is like you
can barely support you you realize that
most people alive today are richer than
ever in human history relatively uh yes
just relatively they're not actually
no like they they have access to things
that poor that the richest of people in
the world didn't have access to
so like for example even in the us
someone can be categorized as low income
even if they have a tv or air
conditioning
which are we can both agree you don't
like a tv isn't needed i don't even have
a tv
so so even when people are low income
they're still at a higher standard of
living than most people were in all of
human history okay and if you if you
have that incentive to where like if you
take away
governmental
handouts essentially then that changes
the voting that changes everything
within government because if i'm voting
say
democrat and they're supporting oh um or
say i'm voting democrat and one year
they support
xyz handouts this that in the third but
the next
um they're like you know what we're
going to actually take that away that
changes someone's vote because they're
like if i'm not going to get that stuff
i'm going to go the other way i'm going
to vote completely different and it
changes the government completely so the
government
will
i won't say never but it will be a long
time before they cut that out because
it's all about
all about the money and that's why your
system is incredibly forward because
you've got this massive loophole where
people are yeah as you said incentivized
to have kids in a situation where they
can't provide for those kids so the
government steps in and because the
government steps in they get somewhat of
a free ride and then more people do that
which is like
it's a system
they have that here too yeah it was an
issue for a while but what we did is we
cut benefits a lot so benefits are not
enough like
if if no woman here is like yeah i'm
going to have a kid to get support from
the government you'll be you'll be more
broke than if you were working like it's
horrible yeah
yeah and that's that's a good thing
because a lot of people were coming in
from developing countries and having
like six kids and then they were getting
like council houses in central london
but can i also say that single mothers
in this country they can get uh
government benefits which are minou i
will say but
the the man will still also have to pay
yeah technically even's out the balance
i guess yeah so yeah i'm just going back
to you said the government should step
in with people that are too poor and
have too many kids
how would they do that or sterilization
no that's that's very extreme that's too
extreme and
i would only agree with that like like a
one a one child policy like china
no
um i would i would
probably start with like culturally
social culturally first thing i think
economically you mean social social
culturally so
it's it's both in the message and the
values you try and impart on people in
the society at large i think that's
that's i think that's where america is
deeply forward because social culturally
you guys push the worst ideals ever okay
like what like this like you know in a
lot of um
i'm not hating on my african-american
brothers and sisters
but a little bit in a lot of the music
but kind of on a positive side it
promotes
um
positivity and hustle and you know
sorry what movement um hip-hop and
african-american aspects of
african-american culture in general but
in on the other side i also see a lot of
normalization of single mother culture
a normalization of having irresponsible
sex you get these guys saying yeah i
went in it raw you know that kind of
stuff a normalization of um the strong
black single mother
which is i i've only seen that happen
with the black community i don't see
people saying you're a strong single
white man you know it's not i mean
single motherhood's rising across all
yeah all demographics like it's
definitely it's the highest in the black
community but you see the trend
because they're most underserved right
so there's
the least educated people who are
watching
videos and xyz
so yeah
they're being left responsible i guess
which is sad i won't say least
educated because if we're going off the
stat that you said earlier about
the percentage of
women that
get abortions
correct me if i'm wrong chat but i know
that um
black women are amongst the
most educated when it comes to
just any form of education maybe
enrolled really is it enrolled
sorry okay sorry the most enrolled so
when they're enrolled hopefully they're
getting an education and
amongst that is that percentage that um
that get those abortions so i don't
think
it's
amongst the uneducated that are um
that are getting abortions but i will
agree with you that there's a lot of
things within the black culture within
everything that stems from uh
just
the forefront that black like um
celebrities or just people who are
pushing
this idea like oh you can do this and
that and be okay i will agree with you
with that that there is a
people are watching from a certain lens
and they're taking that and they're
putting it into their own lives and
thinking they can do the same thing that
this celebrity is doing this rapper is
doing this person is doing that has
three four kids from xyz different baby
mamas and they realize like oh no i i
can't do that because i i don't have the
finances the normalizing your stuff yeah
i think sometimes with celebrity culture
and this is the mistake that a lot of
people do
don't watch what don't listen to what
celebrities say watch what they do
exactly that i don't think a lot of them
do like isn't like future known for like
serenading yeah it's got like 16 kids
right but he that's a luxury lifestyle
he can do it and that's the thing like a
lot of celebrities push luxury
lifestyles on average people
so like another example is women waiting
to have kids because they can do in
vitro fertilization right that's that's
something you can do if you're rich and
you can pay 25 000 per kid
yeah and so they push that on to women
that can't afford it so that's a luxury
lifestyle and the same thing with future
so that that's mad mm-hmm
that is 25 000. yeah is it guaranteed
kid or is it like no you could still
have the first courage to speak you
could still
it's like it could it could never get
fertile you could go through you could
stick yourself um ten times and it never
works but they
they
give you this idea like oh you can go
out live your life do xyz sleep around
with this person that person have this
type of abortion and correct me if i'm
wrong doesn't
having an abortion lower your chance of
actually conceiving a child if you want
it in the long run there could be scar
tissue left in your womb it messes you
up like the people i've known i've got
that it messed them up emotionally yeah
like it's not i think i think a lot a
lot of the things that get missed out in
this conversation is this idea that like
and i guess i i see where you're coming
from and i think you're you're to an
extent right that women wants to have
abortion and they i think it's a
traumatizing experience i don't know i'm
not a woman i've never had an abortion
disclaimer
but
i think i think it's like
for me to comment and be like you know
it's already a kid therefore this is
what you should do with your body and
we're going to stop you from accessing
you know this because i think xyz yeah i
i think the conservatives are dead wrong
on that i think you should have started
with culture you should start with
values you know yeah you can't you can't
impose your values on other people
everybody has like i i don't have i
don't
yeah we do honestly we do we
conservative values are very much
promoted in conservative communities but
the problem is when when people nowadays
have the option between being
irresponsible and responsible what are
they going to pick so we i can't put a
gun to someone's habit and say have my
values but we what we can do is take the
fail-safe and make it illegal so i mean
people make better decisions via the
consequences yeah i don't think they'll
make better decisions though i think
they'll just go to greater irresponsible
levels yeah so question question why in
the uk
when they made abortion free did its go
up
like i could show you a graph it like
skyrocketed after they made it free if
it's more accessible more people are
going to do it if it's less accessible
less people are going to do it whenever
there's no consequence you're far more
free to do it you're far more willing to
do it you're absolutely right on that um
but i will say there are also a number
of people when you restrict access to
those to those to those facilities that
will end up going to the um unregulated
and you know very horrible kind of
abortion clinics that you were well then
they should be they should be prosecuted
yeah if it's illegal they should be
prosecuted exactly you wouldn't use what
they do with their own body yeah but you
wouldn't know what they do to their
child
yeah if uh
this next it may be incorrect but
i think that if
if you get um
a
a bbl
illegally and like someone injects
cement which is essentially what it is
into your body they can
um
they can essentially either get time or
serve whatever for illegally injecting
something into your body
so it's like it's along the same things
if it's if it's if it's illegal
it's illegal you can't like what are you
gonna do you're breaking the law so yeah
and plus we already legislate morality
anyway you wouldn't use the argument
okay there's murder so that we shouldn't
legislate murder is wrong
so just because even there's a law
people will break it the whole point of
it is just it's just to stop the flow
you know obviously there's going to be
leakage that people are still going to
get around it but the whole point of why
i believe the roe v wade decision is
there is to
i agree with you to start the cultural
shift we've got to stop the flood
and that's what they've done by
restricting yeah they've stopped the
flood then over time when people get
used to it becoming difficult
more information about what actually
happens in the womb when a baby is
aborted gets thing then that will change
the culture but there has to be a stop
because there's a massive flood coming
into the
ship and i understand i understand that
perspective and i think it it could be
viable i can see i can see a world where
that that could be viable i i would say
that
um i i still believe it's wrong
to restrict someone's rights um it's a
sticky situation because as we've all
discussed it's about where where where
that life is actually a life
and my way of getting around that
because it's a question that you know
what like like what's when does a zero
become one you know when does infinity
become finite it's one of those
questions
um
and i think a better way of getting
around that isn't restricting people's
rights which i think is i don't think is
really a conservative value i think
consults generally in favor of free
markets bodily autonomy etc
i would have assumed you guys would be
100 on cultural elements on like trying
to support these poorer income kids
trying to support these like underserved
communities that are having like all
these black neighborhoods you guys are
saying yeah you know it's attacking the
black community well where are the
conservative communities are we trying
to support those communities there's
opportunity zones last conservative
president made opportunity zones and
poor income neighborhoods in the us
that's exactly the only thing i'm
talking about that would be excellent
which was great this was a pro-life
president so you can't say that they're
not doing it when he literally did it he
also did the first step act and second
second step act which disproportionately
affected the black community because you
take the father out of the home because
they're in jail for low like petty crime
and there's a lot of democrats that said
they were going to do something about it
they didn't and who did something about
it the conservatives yeah so that's
that's a pro-life president that's
that's i would i would be in support of
that
go ahead sorry i'm just saying i would
fully support that that um i don't know
any conservative presidents that took
those kind of measures but see uh one
thing that
i believe
didn't um
it was because not because like that
wasn't the sole reason but it was that
idea of like
oh um
and i can the reason why i'm saying this
because i could see people thinking like
this is like oh they're taking away my
he's pro-life so he's taking away my
choice so i'm not even going to look at
anything else that he's doing for
my community or for anybody else he's
taking away my choice so i'm not even
going to vote for him to bring him back
in office to take away my choice to do
what i want to do with my body it's
it's crazy to think like that but people
thought like that and to know that he
was doing stuff to help out the black
community help out low-income areas but
it was certain things like pro-life and
taking away a choice that
just looked past other things that would
be able to help yeah well he messed up
by taking away joy don't restrict
people's rights no he didn't like i said
that argument with us and pearl you
probably can correct me about what
caused the american civil war it was
because of slavery because obviously i
think it was the northern states that
wanted it or didn't want it
and obviously that would have they the
slave on them said you're taking my
right to to slave owners so and
obviously when that decision was made i
agree that this is what it was was
controversial i mean america went into a
civil war but gradually it started the
trends whereby obviously
blacks and whites were recognized the
same under the law this is why i believe
the long-term strategy with the uh roe v
wave decision here so i have i have an
article that kind of backs up what
you're saying is gonna i'm just gonna
read this real quick on march 6 1857 us
supreme court chief justice roger b
tammy handed down the supreme court's
decision in the landmark case of dred
versus scott versus stanford
in 1846 dred scott and his wife harriet
had been slaves residing with their
masters in free territories for almost
nine years being prompted by their
friends and local minister dred scott
sued for their freedom after several
years of litigation the scots finally
appealed to the u.s supreme court the
court's decision stated that the scots
were to remain slaves regardless of
their place of their place of residence
however chief justice taney did not stop
there he further stated that dred scott
was not a citizen of the u.s he could
not bring sue into federal courts
regardless of the issue further martini
made it clear that slaves were no more
than personal property and subsequently
had no ability to lay claim on freedom
by 1860 the overall slave population was
close to 4 million or 39 percent of the
overall population of the confederacy
slaves in the south carolina the state
with the largest percentage of slaves
per capita outnumbered whites at a rate
of almost three to one with the greatest
percentage in small towns such as goose
creek where the slave population was
almost 80 when slavery ended whites
began institution instituting laws that
required blacks to be able to read and
write to be eligible to vote to curtail
the possibility of sudden influx of
blacks running for political office
since almost the entire former slave
population had neither scales blacks
were effectively shut out of the
political process preventing them from
passing laws more equitable to all races
a legal wall of separation between
blacks and whites deemed blacks as
inferior not even worthy of occupying
the same spaces as white until it was
the role
of a servant this dichotomy in the
culture continued until the in until the
enactment of the civil rights act of
1964 in the voting rights act of 1965.
eugenicists however were unwilling to
allow the racial divide in america to be
healed richard nixon john d rockefeller
and others pushed to erect a third
barrier to keep the races separate their
initiatives as we know from the nixon
comments were to remove obstacles to
abortion particularly in communities we
don't want too many of as justice
ginsburg said such high frequency of
abortions within the black community
inevitably creates far-reaching
consequences not only on women who have
attained obtained abortions but also on
the entire population recent census
results reveal one
one such consequence stating that
african americans have been surpassed by
hispanics as the largest minority group
in the u.s michael novak the george w
jewett scholar at the american
enterprise institute had the following
to say in regards to political and
social ramifications of abortion in the
african-american society since the
number of current living blacks is 31
million the missing 10 million
represents an enormous loss for without
abortion america's black community would
now number 41 million persons it would
be 35 percent larger than it currently
is abortion has kept and swept through
the black community cutting down every
fourth member consider this if those 10
million children had not been aborted
the voting power of the black community
would now be at 16 nationally rather
than the 13
blacks who cry in desperation for
political change
must recognize that the majority of the
civic change
civic leaders support political policies
which would destroy their future
constituency it is it is not beyond
reason to conclude that the
representatives in the halls of congress
today had it not been for abortion
platforms supported by so many liberal
and black black and white leaders today
as a result of abortions blacks would
have prevented themselves have prevented
themselves from gaining greater
political opportunity
i'm sorry i thought that was more
related to the slaves
than it was but
yeah sorry
i think most of the arguments to around
abortion are based on like christian
christian fundamentalism um biology
because 95 of biologists say that life
begins at conception
yeah and i would say going for this
natural law
natural law yeah right to life
right to life yeah
okay so no people use that as a digger
christian fundamentalism but it's
literally you can use natural law for a
pro-life argument
yeah yeah yeah i mean abortion's
horrible so i mean in an ideal world
there would be no abortions
so let's make it illegal
but and i do well everyone would have
the choice
and just no one would do it but shitty
people exist mm-hmm
[Music]
even
why wouldn't you just make it illegal so
people can't do it
you don't want to restrict human rights
individual rights but but that's the
individual right to kill a life which
you agree is life well it's all it's
arguable at what point is legal
ignorance in life which is well 95 of
biologists say at conception
yeah it is a is a stick i'm not saying
it's not a life that is that is a life
but then obviously there's a difference
between an embryo and a fully developed
baby i hope you know we all understand
that right
um but yeah that choice is important
right i think an easier way for
conservatives to think about it is if
you don't want to ever be caught up in
an abortion situation then don't don't
get anyone pregnant i think that's for
anybody
but especially especially for
the conservatives especially for the men
for the women like you you know you'd go
through you get all these iuds etc yeah
that's an easy fix right so you won't
get you won't need to get an abortion
because you'll never get pregnant if you
have that for the men get the snip or
you know make sure you're strapped up
properly make sure you're with women
who have the same values as you etc i
think i think that's that that's that's
to me sounds more reasonable than
stopping restricting rights which i
think is very it's just very like i
agree i think it's the ultimate fix to
it all yeah just fix fix the people and
the underlying issues
before the philosophical but the problem
is you can't like people are people
there's always going to be shitty people
in a society that are going to be
irresponsible regardless so there should
be a consequence in place yeah for the
people that are just going to do what
they're going to do you can't you can't
fix society's values i can't go over to
jeff if jess was pro pro choice and she
was just wilding in these streets like
i could i couldn't go up to jess and say
don't do that i could do it but it's not
going to change what she does she's a
grown-ass woman yeah but what did change
what you what you do well
knowing that if i get pregnant i have to
keep it because abortion isn't an option
or i have to go get a back alley
abortion
all right
yeah so making keeping the kid a
punishment
it's not it's not
it's not making that's how you would no
it's not making
keeping a kid a punishment is you
thinking if i get myself in this
situation
in this whatever state i'm in
it's illegal i could serve jail time for
having an abortion or i'm going to have
to pay for an abortion pay extra money
out of my pocket to get a flight to
drive gas is astronomical in the states
right now and then pay for somewhere to
stay while i have this abortion to um
to recuperate
it's like it's not or just practice safe
sex like which one would i rather do
the public shaman's a good idea as well
though yeah bring back shane i'm a firm
believer and bring back shaming you
should be ashamed yeah
and my mom she she was she was a teen
pregnant she got pregnant as a kid
she she did the right thing she gave it
up for adoption
but she had shame can i just question
okay jim's not a bad thing this is this
is slightly love you mom this is
slightly off topic right this is
slightly off topic but i'm a personal
trainer and
99 of all the clients who end up
transforming or undergo a weight loss
journey
are the ones i openly call a fat [ __ ] to
their face
true people can disagree with what they
want and most people do
but the results the numbers is what i'm
looking at and ultimately you said it
yourself
it's well i think it might have been you
it's
looking at what they do not what they
say yeah because if you were to
sugarcoat that oh no you look good they
wouldn't they wouldn't come they
wouldn't work out they wouldn't do
anything but since you tell them the
truth and you say like hey if you don't
if you don't do this there's going to be
implications either you choose to do it
or you don't
exactly so what would you guys say to
the
idea that um this conservative focus on
restricting rights over actually like
affecting change in other ways
um to the same ends right which is less
abortions happier families um is in line
with uh the handmaid's tale and it's
more about power more propaganda how was
that no but the handmaid's tale is
obviously extremist feminist dystopia
right that they're saying
men look at women as like just baby
machines and we'll have this society
where women are seen as like just
birthing machines and have no choice in
the matter okay okay okay so
so
in the handmaid's tale okay
they kidnap these women
and hold them down
while the wife holds the the [ __ ] down
while the dude the husband has sex with
her
i'm not sure that's the same i don't
even know why i'm explaining this but
i'm not sure why
i don't know why that's the same thing
as a girl meeting mr tall dark and
handsome
not being on birth control
not wearing a condom
and then choosing
and then now she she has a situation she
put herself in
and now she doesn't have the option to
have an abortion one's right one's not
yeah
great great great great great yeah well
it's not really about those kind of
details more about the general premise
wait wait it's more about the general
premise so so the detail that one girl
was graped and one girl chose it
oh it's a fictional it's a fictional
dystopian novel you brought it you
brought it up but the point i'm trying
to well not the point of the question
i'm asking is right
it's it's about power people say it's
about power it's about um a patriarchal
society or whatever um affecting power
over women and their bodies
and a similar things happens in that in
that fictional dystopia obviously it's
extreme it is a netflix show right
i hope we all understand that i'm not
saying women are being held by like
conservative men etc but
you know do you do you see any any kind
of
what do you say to that in terms of the
idea because i can i can't even answer
that what we should do as conservative
media is put the opposite side and say
okay look at a dystopia whereby you see
um
uh mothers killing their babies after
their birth i have a film on on that
yeah yeah
which is ultimately no different it's an
equal equally disturbing
yeah so that's what we should counter
balance that so that would be my thing
because i think
one thing one person said is a
conservative commentator his name is
bill whittle and he said this
you cannot lecture
people out of liberalism you got to
entertain them out of liberalism lecture
people entertain them yeah because what
type of what's what's made people become
liberal they've been entertained into
liberalism not educated into liberalism
most of our films are liberal
yeah yeah most of our films are
obviously projecting a walk agenda
and what the problem with the
conservatives doing they think that okay
we can undo that by giving you boring
lectures no you've got to deal with the
culture with your films
because i promise you if some of these
uh
artists actors were
switched it and talked a different way
it would it wouldn't be an instant
change but people would look and if
these
if these rappers were talking more about
education getting your back
educationally this that and third don't
have don't have five four baby mamas
work hard get a family be in a
two-parent home it may it wouldn't have
an instant change but more and more
people it would influence them to change
yeah would you sing wealth inequality i
think if more people had a better
standard of living in terms of more
frequently people have better standard
of living than ever in history that's
it's just jealousy yeah what what like
why why why is why is what someone uh
someone else's success what does it take
away from you if you're doing better
than ever in human history what's poor
now is not the same as what was pulled
back you're right they have air
conditioning and tvs so like for example
like like paul said earlier there could
be someone right now who has
they said they have a [ __ ] tv but
they've got running water
that person is considered poor
but there's somebody in another country
right now where poverty to them real
poverty is actually being sat on the
streets with no food no water and
nothing else yeah yeah and you're
nigerian you're simple
you're supposed to yeah
yeah um
i think also what happens also is a um
like for example let me give you a
scenario let's say you're working for a
boss you've got three people working on
the bus he gives you a standard salary
but for some reason of the goodness of
your heart he gives you a hundred grand
how would you feel i'm great yeah okay
second guy in the company he gives him a
million pounds how would you feel
it gives another person a million pounds
yeah
not so great you see already that's what
that's envy
is
because of envy he's saying that mindset
of the one percent is evil that is off
of envy yeah because because if
everybody's rising up why is it no
listen why is it a bad thing if
everybody's doing better than ever in
the course of human history in terms of
standard of living yeah like why why why
do we hate on the one percent if
anything like they're an anomaly
in most of history everybody's been poor
and so now now someone does something
that no one's ever done it should be
applauded it shouldn't be it shouldn't
be hated on i think you're conflating
like poor
and standard of living whether it's
relative relative relative poverty and
actually like absolute poverty so i
think you you'll find no i'm saying come
on on a global perspective there are
less people in poverty than ever in
history yes but you can't deny that
relative poverty exists
under certain salary you know if you
have a salary under a certain amount in
london you cannot afford a decent place
to live you can barely afford decent
fresh food and you know to use tfo we
have the most expensive rail system in
the world so would you say to that hey
man you've got it you've got an iphone
you're not really poor i mean people 50
years ago didn't have iphones and
therefore yeah i mean essentially if
they're if they're technically poor how
can you afford a thousand dollar plus i
feel 20 pounds a month they're going
exactly they're gonna find a way to make
the money yeah so
so it's it's
it's yeah because i can i can speak from
a standpoint of where growing up in
a low-income area and struggling so i
can understand being poor like wondering
like oh
where where where's our next meal gonna
come from are we gonna have money this
week i don't know maybe i can speak from
that but i know that now
a days it's so easy to make money it's
really
yo yeah it's so easy to make money in
any situation you can you can buy stuff
if you can find the money to buy a
thousand dollar iphone you can find the
money to buy a thousand dollar sneakers
resell them for two thousand dollars and
then you have you guys how did you get
this job
i just showed up yeah
it's it's so like nowadays it's so easy
to
make money seems seems a bit
unrealistic i don't think everyone has
the same access no i don't think
everyone has the same mindset because on
all of them in all honesty like there
was so many like people that had the
same opportunity just did to work here
come on this is the best job ever we get
to work on a youtube channel and and i
honestly gave this opportunity to so
many people jess was the only one that
showed up on time and came when she was
going to come yeah i i get and this is
you know
a common republican or conservative
mindset as that it's just how you think
and that's why you're poor and you know
we could all be youtube stars and
whatever i think there is merit to that
there is like the idea that yeah like is
it you know
there is a lot of opportunity out there
even more so than ever before because we
have the internet so
poverty is not localized in the same way
it was because you can you can make a
youtube channel from the middle of the
bahamas or the middle of a nigerian
market blow up like that italian guy the
italian black guy right
yeah but at the same time there are also
less jobs because of automation they're
also higher than ever living costs so
when you balance everything out you know
it is actually getting hot i think you
can't get around if you can't say oh
you're better off than your parents 50
years ago because you earn more money
but actually when you look at what that
money can buy you i would say you get
less you're better off because you have
a higher standard of living
so it's if if you make choices to buy
things you can't afford
that that's a you probably suspend
that's a spending problem what is
something so i'm saying if you're
as i said before air conditioning
tvs
a thousand dollar iphone
my dad was
very well off and he he drove the same
car for 20 years i see people that can't
afford it all the time buying clothes
they can't afford buying cars they can't
afford in london
in london like yeah
why are you wilding with the prices out
here i think i think that starts again
would you say this though could you be
uh maturely wealthy but still be poor
materially wealthy will still be
important it depends on what you mean by
poor doesn't it so what means mindset
absolutely
again athletes when they buy stuff it
depreciates in assets whereby you look
at mark zuckerberg
whether i think he's evil but i like his
business mindset whereby he will wear
the same suit to work and doesn't need
to buy drive a lamborghini
you'll you're still
again i get that
looking at the conservative like it's
not conservative it is a very
conservative thing because the idea that
it's all it's all your mindset and i
think there is a lot of merit to that
that is true in a lot of ways but i
think it's very extreme to act like that
is just the reality for everyone to look
at like global poverty especially in
places like london where like if you
look at the quality of houses in london
because of how popular it is it's
like people are paying 900 pounds a
month for like a room and you're going
to walk into that room and say bro
there's a tv and air conditioning in
here you're actually way better off than
x y they could still be living on you
move out of london yeah you could but
then you have to sacrifice a job for
example a lot of those people will be
living in a lot of the worst off people
are living in like um retail
working in retail or jobs where they
can't they can't commute four hours for
manchester in and then you have to
factor in the cost of that an
opportunity there's no jobs in like the
middle of guilford their life's about
trade-offs
like like this i think living in london
is a luxury
[Music]
like honestly it's a luxury
and ultimately at the end of the day
there is a decision that you can make
whether it's to move away whether it's
to go for that higher paying job i mean
if you if you just look at the fact that
look we can all i think we can all agree
here there's more opportunity in london
now than ever has been yeah and if
somebody can cross a border with we're
talking the most downtrodden level of
poverty for example you've probably seen
this with mexicans trying to cross the
border right
if they can cross a border
and make it and they've been so many
instances that i've seen where they have
i agree with pearl here in that
ultimately i do to an extent agree i see
where you're coming from i think
ultimately it's a mindset issue if
somebody is filthy rich because they
built it that's the mindset which means
if they lost it all tomorrow they could
build it again because of their mindset
whereas somebody can be so poor of mind
that you could they could win the
lottery tomorrow and lose it all because
mentally they were poor the majority of
lottery winners go broke yeah yeah yeah
and athletes as well and i will go back
to what you said earlier i think it's uh
um
i mean a mentality a mental mindset but
also influence to talking about the
black community as well they'll see
these
kids we'll see or just people in general
and not just in the black community just
across the board will see these people
of influence once they once these people
get money what do they end up buying all
these big old chains all these cars is
that in the third and they don't
handle their money well but
nobody cares about that because they
flash you when they walk through the
room they shine bling
look at them they look good and it's
giving that uh that image like oh when
you get money this is the stuff you buy
this is how you um can spend your money
instead of
initiating or um teaching people hey
when you get your money use it this way
invest it build do stuff to where your
money can make money so i
i agree that they're still poverty
because
people aren't being taught the the way
to
properly use their money and it's a
mindset if
if you are if you are broke
and you have money because i've seen
people say this i've said this myself
i'll have money and i'll be like man i'm
broke i'm broke i'm broke i don't know
what to do with my money because it's
that mindset that i don't
i
it's just a mindset that some people
have they could
astronomically have money but they're
going to have that mindset like oh i'm
broke i'm broke and broke or just an
irresponsible mindset as well we see
this on a smaller scale now the fact
that it isn't just a top level influence
at the top one percent who are balling
we see it all the time with instagram in
the fact that people will portray a
certain lifestyle they'll fly to a
certain country with [ __ ] all money and
they'll portray a certain lifestyle sit
on a certain boat but then if you if you
meet them in person you realize how
broke they are
it's it's worked its way down
to the point where now
the influences aren't just those at the
top level the influencers are the ones
who sit next to you on a train but train
a certain life make it to your making
take it to your maker but now somebody
else yeah at their level of poverty
let's call it is now going to think well
i'm going to do the same thing and now
they have screwed up
i i don't know
i think on this case facts facts don't
care about your feelings i think we can
we can easily just chart people's
earning potential people's living costs
it's clear as day that people are
falling further and further
so what about the fact that we have a
higher standard of living than ever in
human history do you not care about that
fact that's great but that doesn't mean
it doesn't mean what that doesn't mean
that you're not in poverty
okay so so if you in all if we're
looking to look at all of human history
and you you get to be born today and you
have a better standard of living than in
all of human history
you're not going to take that as a w
that's a win in some ways a loss in some
way it's not it's not that simple it's
trying to simplify it to be like we have
tvs and air conditioning now therefore
no one's pulling i think what happens is
i think there's a distance between your
needs and your wants
your wants are your iphones and your tvs
and your luxury items but your needs are
your food no one in the west is starving
is is suffering from starvation
as a rule that's true they could be the
exact exception but as a rule in the
west we don't start from starvation just
true but there are a lot of people
suffering from
expensive housing as is happening all
over the world yeah that's a big factor
would you say they're like it's their
mindset yeah that is create increasing
those rents you could say i mean
it's supply and demand yeah it's because
they chose to live in a luxury city so
they so okay so they move out of the
city yes right
but then now they're paying more for
transport costs and you know
no one people can't just move
you you're on a city people move to
london because of jobs
and people stay here because of jobs
we're not here because like it's just
fun to walk around london all the jobs
are in london go outside drive an hour
outside of london on this almost you
make you make less money outside of
london i'm sure but you decrease your
standard of living
like that's that's the same thing in the
us
with new york and if you go from new
york to nebraska you're going to make
less into nebraska but you just decrease
your standard of living and it's a like
pearl said earlier it's a it's a
trade-off
if you're
and i can speak from california it's
expensive if california if you want to
if you want to live in california you
have to
essentially have money and if you can't
you got to figure it out or you take
that trade off and say oh or even i
won't even say california so i'll say la
you have to take that trade off i'm
going to live in a city that's maybe 30
minutes away but it takes me an hour two
hour drive to get to work to be able to
afford where i'm living or i'm just
going to live in l.a be right up the
street from work and have to figure out
how i'm going to do it if i have the
mindset i was like oh i'm going to get
it done i'm going to get that money or
if i have the mindset like oh
i'll just struggle i'll just be broke
i'll just figure out what i'm going to
do then you're going to struggle and
you're going to be broke yeah all three
of those were a decision to move away to
level up or to accept poverty where you
live in the struggle all three of them
were a decision that means that yeah is
mindset and mindset only yeah but the
point you're missing is not everyone has
those decisions not everyone can move
out not everyone can choose like
i think you're using anomalies to try
and gloss over the fact that
most people are facing a similar
situation they can afford less food and
their rent is more expensive and they're
paying i'm not using a llama i'm
speaking from
experience i'm speaking from
life yeah but i'm speaking from life as
well and i see people who are living in
the same places affording less they
can't be validation
inflation is huge you're right yeah and
and the the the housing market is
ridiculous and not everyone can just
move out this a lot of housing a lot of
wealth equality would be
kind of um reduced by making people be
able to work remotely by law and then as
you're saying yeah you could just use
that businesses to make allow people so
so my youtube channel i have to allow my
producer to work remotely by law no i
wouldn't
that would that would help him
financially if he had to travel a long
time to get here xyz so there is merit
to that in a lot of cases where that
could improve someone's standard of
living
yeah but that doesn't mean you'd have to
do it that doesn't mean he'll take he'll
take the opportunity i'm just saying
that would obviously add to their
standard of living because yeah but by
the way though even if you say working
from home someone has to do the physical
work i'm into it so someone has to look
after you your routers your switches to
make sure those tell us obviously but
i'm still making a common sense point
which is what's already happening which
is people are working remotely more and
more as a way of saving on costs so
again it's just a fact it's not it's not
my opinion it's not like i'm not saying
everyone should work remotely so that
that's that's what i'm saying where like
the poverty the wealth inequality issue
is not something you can dance around
with mindset it actually needs practical
solutions and it is worse now than ever
there was a massive mindset aspect to it
yeah no one's gonna deny that but not
everyone has those choices i need to
understand that
what practical solutions
what practical solutions so so that that
law that you just proposed whether it's
required they have to work from home i
just gave you an example where that
wouldn't work what practical solutions
i think
making it more attractive for peop
people who don't need to be in work
physically to be able to work more
remotely and that would allow a lot more
people that i know who don't necessarily
need to be in office to move out to
manchester and pay half in rent and
right now already or just jobs in
general the jobs that they're right now
working remotely isn't for every job
guys do you i know but i'm saying do you
think businesses should have the freedom
to choose that or do you think the
government should force them to i
wouldn't be in favor of the government
forcing restricting the businesses right
to choose their employees
employees and how they work but i do
think that a lot of things we could do
and again these are already happening so
you can pay me as crazy if you want to
but this is just like not this new one
obviously it's just happening already no
i'll give you a bond there is nuance to
your argument and stuff and obviously
with the pandemic it did make people to
re-evaluate why do i need to spend two
hours commuting to central london every
single week but the problem is it
affects another part of the economy you
know the
small coffee shops that people went to
as well so
i think there has to be a conversation
about the um
the way people work but that's the
marketplace so literally if you want to
get the best employee and he wants to
work from home an employee has to
consider that but i don't think it
should be an enforced thing by the
government i think it should be yeah the
marketplace should determine that i
would agree on that but people if people
want a remote job there's umpteen
options now it may not be at the company
you want yeah but i'm pretty sure
there's another company that offers
remote so there's always there's always
a um
a choice or a um a trade-off rather this
company if i wanted to work for google
and they said no you have to be here to
work for us i'll go see what amazon's
doing i'll go see what exactly bing is
doing this is there's always an other
options i mean there is also extreme
competition for those jobs but i get
what you're saying
another another thing that would really
help um
you know cost of living right now is
other alternatives in food so
arable land in the world is decreasing
significantly we need to find higher
yield ways of providing food so i think
i saw some stuff about people using like
um growing food under like water and
that has like 10 times the yield there's
this whole idea about eating insects
because it's fast and complete protein
there's all these challenges okay if you
want to eat insects you can do that wait
we don't want to
i'm african man you know we're both
african
i'm from the us i promise you we do not
have a food problem
wealth equal inequality is an issue i
wouldn't say it's envy
i would say as a lot of people are
suffering
more than
it
has been experienced for the last like
maybe generation in some ways and people
are looking for alternatives i think
when you talk about mindset people are
looking for alternatives that's why
remote working is being a thing that's
why people are looking at all these
different lifestyle habits i think you
need to i think it'd be fair to get over
to the give it to the people that like
yeah people are trying
it sounds like you're trying to say like
you're trying to get more for giving
less but i feel like what they're saying
is you know what if you want it go get
it like you want to live in london you
have to pay for it you know what i'm
saying yeah you're trying to say that
okay i want to work in london but i want
to pay like as if i'm paid in wells or
something
you know i mean so i feel like what
you're trying to say is that you're
trying to get more by giving less but i
don't i feel like i don't agree with
that i feel like you know what you
should give you want more you should
give more you want more money
do some big work like what they say if
you want big boy money do some big way
what right so i mean what i'm saying is
wealth equal inequality is a big issue
you're
the point on like oh it's just in your
mind i don't think cut it cut cuts the
cake at all i think there are real
concrete issues with the housing market
with inflation with the fact that you
know employee earnings as compared to
ceo and earnings are way higher than
like you know in previous times i don't
say it's in your mind i say it's a lack
of skills
it's a lack you don't have skills the
market wants
so you should figure out how to get
skills that the market needs people are
working though so what about the people
that are working now and can't afford to
because they're working with the skills
that they have aren't that valuable so
they need to learn better skills
get a better job no it's not it's not to
learn get better skills
so you can learn drop shipping you could
like like even if this channel tanks
tomorrow the skills i have i'd be hired
at another channel
because i know how to run all the
equipment i know how to i know how to
edit a video yeah i know how to film
like even before it even cost like like
i know i have equipment now but i
started on my phone but but can you
appreciate that not everyone's you not
everyone has your skill set not everyone
has your network no not everybody is
everyone's educated as you she's not
saying that every not every she's not
saying that she
what you're saying is not everyone but
she wasn't there she didn't know that
she didn't know none of this stuff when
she started it i get it she grew into
that but the point i'm making is because
not everyone's you not everyone wants to
have access to you know upskilling like
upskilling is a massive thing i'm an i.t
upscaling is a massive thing but not
everyone can learn to code python
engineering i can tell that because i
work in a massive it's
iq is a issue yeah you have to have a
certain iq to do things yes i mean i
don't really buy into iq as much but i
say that iq is a factor like your
problem-solving ability there's also
people's interest there's also like yes
um yes i agree with you yes and there's
also all these elements so saying yeah
like you can you could just learn
you know is is it is a bit more um
not extreme i don't think it's an
extreme point but i i think i'm a bit
more like to the left of that there's a
nuance to it there's a lot of nuance
yeah yeah but also i think um
back in probably your father's
generation and my parents generation
um if you stay if you were hired by one
company you stayed there from
apprenticeship to retirement that was
the norm
right now especially with millennials
and i believe what's what's before us
jen
said
no no
next year and obviously it's boomers and
stuff
um before that
our generation we're probably gonna
change careers three or four times to
different avenues and we have to adapt
to the market you said you're into it
most of the stuff had to be hand when
you're doing programming you have to do
it manually but most of the stuff is
automated so we also have to adapt to a
much changing world so and that's a
that's a massive issue and that's scary
that is that is a scary like universal
income i think is inevitable
oh my god did you see what happened in
the u.s with that that worked out
terribly what happened in the in the u.s
they were giving out stimulus checks
it was like it was like oprah like you
get a check
yeah but everyone wasn't different
though no it's the same thing you give
people a certain amount of income and
they just don't work
you're paying people not to work why
would they not work yeah if i if no it's
not if i had the choice to get money and
do nothing
why would i not take it yeah it's the
same hey what she's saying like there's
a certain limit if you don't hit that
you're gonna get that check so people
are you know what let me do a couple
hours and just sit back people are
abused people are abused
here as well it happened here as well
but i don't that's not really universal
credit that's just being people handing
out money to random people
like universal credit is a lot more of a
sophisticated sophisticated system but i
think that's inevitable because i think
you're going to see a lot more jobs
automate and another thing you guys
forget is that they're limited jobs and
there's higher competition so i think in
the future we'll see this more and more
there's a shortage in a lot of
industries we just read a whole thing
about how there's a shortage in nursing
there is yeah and and like plumbers yeah
electricians yeah but there's also a lot
of automation and pilots as well pilots
there's shortages like the population is
decreasing there's a shortage yeah
people don't want to put in the work to
get those yeah those jobs well maybe
they don't have access to those
opportunities
they don't know that like
you could you could be a plumber you
could be or whatever right now i know a
lot of people most poverty i agree with
you guys is in the mind to an extent of
like people you just don't know that bro
like
amazon is training people
in software engineering you don't know
what you don't know you can legit apply
for it right now but i wouldn't go as
far to say that like
everyone could apply for that and like
that's that's the problem that's the
cure for you know because that doesn't
matter
yeah there's limited jobs yeah but
everyone has the internet and can google
free apprenticeship programs
it's like the great equalizer yeah and
exactly especially right now whereby
every organization wants to be woke if
you're black and from an ethnic minority
you could be a
a
black lesbian that's attracted to cats
you are the minority of the minority
trust me google and netflix will want
you to be that poster child
better yet why don't we all just
identify with our own adjectives and
pronouns i'm a billionaire where's my
money yes
okay i'm gonna read some super chats
real quick um
okay guys so
um don't forget to like the video and
sign up for our memberships because
we're doing exclusive behind the scenes
content also the second half of our live
streams are going to be members only
okay so
live one a reminder that california
homeless folks are getting paid to be
homeless just human exactly skid row in
california begs to differ on your
starvation point to white hat's point
the system does require people to be at
the bottom
cereal acts i commute three hours one
way five days a week for work i don't
like it i don't want to do it but it's
the choice i made to support my family
life is about choices and trade-offs the
uk economist there's no excuse in the uk
everyone has the opportunity example i
started a successful company but my
older siblings made excuses why he
didn't want to better his finances
mindset is key
ian mack shout out to jess for coming
when she was told to
i can't read this person's name but
funny thing about the handmaid's tale it
would be the direct result of a societal
collapse marxism masquerading feminism a
self-fulfilling prophecy 90 free tope um
if a baby isn't a person because a
person said
said so then what's stopping me from
saying you want are a person white cap
um
why why
why the right doesn't apply the same
logic to guns if less people were killed
every year by guns the population would
be higher ban guns why is that not the
argument of the right that's a whole
other show um delhi 80-79 in a perfect
world we should do that yeah you should
yeah we should do that one today okay in
a perfect world no
one should murder people it shouldn't be
illegal though because it restricts
people's rights white hat um dragon
stallion one zero zero one dude in the
white hat needs to stop living by
talking points the snip only has a 30
chance of reversibility after 10 years
just human beo and though and the white
hats are starting to sound like
eugenicists the elite reproduced while
the feeble-minded or terminated
eugenicist mission complete waxy game
central the civil war started because
the north and the south had laws they
agreed but the north would not honor
them and the south succeeded in the
north attacked 93 tope
90 free to pay as a man you if you can't
protect your baby from your own girl
what good are you women are not gods
they can't kill babies just because they
are women dragon stallion abortion is
not a constitutional right it is a
privilege and there are different things
thp network bro if you're going to bash
african-americans say it with your chest
back it up with stats and stand on your
square project tube why is it considered
a double homicide in 30 plus states in
the united states if a pregnant woman is
murdered by an unborn baby has no rights
truth bearer media given the gun
has given this guy self-hatred of black
people ian mack um
chat members only bad change in my
opinion probably because you're not a
member sign up
house of hats pop population control we
are in a birth rate decline you sound
like a super villain we are low on birth
stop saying that population controlled
two generations will be short on people
ian mack guy in the corner is a classic
classic leftist i can oppress the
oppressed people out of oppression nice
intention but it ends horribly get this
man a red pill jmarcus 89 they there
should be a fine for abortion and it
should pay couples to adopt donovan
fletcher for british folks across the
pond confused on how this happened it's
an imperative that you do not you that
you understand the
constitution does not give us rights it
acknowledges naturally bestowed rights
rose ruling was an activist was activist
legislation waxa game central i'm behind
but how do you reconcile your belief
that if it's not if it's not murder
because a baby is a virus but then in
the same breath say killing a mother and
a fetus is a double homicide if if so
abortion is murder cereal x thanks for
the answer jess next time for more cams
um john belcher the government should
not be able to decide what i have to put
or keep in my body if i want it out then
i should be allowed to take it out live
live one is it okay to use lethal force
against a doctor about to perform an
abortion in a similar way self-defense
is used i would argue yes h.a the
burning building analogy was a very good
one the main point was that abortion has
to do when life starts that's when
that's why in many countries the point
of viability medical
definition house of has usa if the prego
mom tests positive for drugs they take
the child away once it's born it's
pro-life um decide so when it goes stops
going back and forth okay then i've read
that one already let me
um
do the super chats one more time also
guys like the video it's really
important to the algorithm
um i think we're at about 800 likes
let's see if we can get to 900 that
would be really really helpful um live
one or okay i did that one already okay
well
um i think well i just want to say you
guys do you know like in the uk i'm
considered like conservative right
legit
seriously people people people people
think my views are very conservative and
so it's funny that like
here i'm considered a a blue pill beta
male 1
or leftist or whatever
yo you should you should come back next
time we can talk about what we agree on
just do it yeah next show though because
i'm i'm going to wrap this show up so
why don't we go around i
very much i want to give a big shout out
to you if i had my buttons i would do
like a little applause because i know
it's really hard to be like the only one
in a room to defend a point so i do
appreciate you coming um and standing on
you know your argument so um why don't
we go around and everyone tell the
people where they can find you in any
closing thoughts that you have
uh you can find me at santochoku
h u k s-u-n-t-o-c-h-u-k-dot u on
instagram
um and
what was that what else what's up any
closing thoughts here thoughts yeah
abortion is ugly guys like um you know i
think we need to stop this polarizing
environment where we wanna we wanna act
like people who approach the poor life
are just okay with infant homicide it's
very very ugly but in my view
restricting people's rights isn't the
right way to go i think there's a lot of
cultural um change that we can do to to
have the outcomes we i think everyone
wants which is more wanted kids and
happier families
so you can find me instagram which is
i've just started the instagram up so
uh jordan fuller officials where you can
find me on instagram and my closing
thoughts are we should absolutely be
mainstreaming um pro-life
and also mainstreaming accountability
um you can find me on instagram it's
girl underscore jess
and then you can find me on put in the
chat what her new username should be
yeah i'm trying to think of a new one
someone told me that i should change it
they sent a super chat saying i should
change it give me a new one um
and then you can find me on youtube as
well it's just it's your girl jess um
final thoughts
i just think that
with this um
new overturn of this law as i just want
people to think more that's the biggest
thing i don't want to take in away
anybody's rights i mean i can't do
anything i'm not the government but i
just want people to be more cognizant of
their actions and what they're doing and
what they're getting themselves into and
really think about like oh if i'm
engaging in this there's a possibility
that this might happen so just think
yep and you can find me on any 1983 and
one of my closing thoughts is is like um
when will before make a decision make
sure we look at the primary sources and
not secondary sources
most of the
issues that we suffer is not necessarily
uh we're ill informed so for example we
will hear someone said this or
conservative
mean this but they haven't looked at the
person they haven't even spoken to a
conservative to find out what we
actually believe so just looking at
primary sources before we will make a
decision
yeah you can find me on instagram my
name is ibrahim on the scope s dot i dot
d and my closing thought really is just
educate yourself in this topic before
you make any decisions and like i said
just like he was saying you know it's
your decision but really educate
yourself before you go ahead and do
something and learn from the right
places and the right people because it's
a really really you know big decision to
make so educate yourself and
take responsibility for whatever
decision you come to make
okay guys thank you so much for coming
you guys were great um guys do not
forget to subscribe to the channel okay
i i see the analytics like half y'all
don't even subscribe which is bogus
because i know you have watched two or
more of my videos and you know if you've
watched two or more of my videos and you
don't subscribe we have beef okay
sign up for the memberships because
you'll get to see exclusive
behind-the-scenes content you'll also
get to be a part of our live chat the
second half of the show
like the video on your way out that is
really important to the algorithm and we
will talk to you